And we're live.
What's up
dude?
You're on a rollercoaster ride.
What does it like to be the champ?
Ah,
what's the feeling like this is fresh for you?
Oh,
well first of all,
I just want to say,
man,
it's such an honor to be here.
Um,
the honors mind,
I never,
I'm gonna I'm gonna be honest.
Um,
um,
my thing is I'm just going to be 100% and totally transparent.
I was never,
I never really watched the show.
I never really kind of heard of this show.
Of course I heard of you and all the things you do.
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
it's fear factor guy,
you know?
But I never really heard of the show until like after like a fight or two in the
UFC and people are like tagging me in shit.
Like Yo Joe Rogan's talking by Joe Wrong and talking about you and pocket.
I'm like fucking podcasts.
Cause I'd never listened to podcasts at the time.
I was like,
what are you talking about?
Till I finally started listening,
I'm like,
oh this dude is for real.
This dude got some,
some,
some pool.
You got some people watching this shit,
random people would tag me.
Oh,
Joel was talking about you today on the podcast.
I'm like,
Oh man,
this guy's for real.
And then every time after that that I see you,
I'm like sub Gel.
Yeah,
we've been talking about you for a long time man.
We were just with your friend out there.
We're watching a video of us talking about you back when you were ranked number
12.
And I was saying,
I think you can fight for the title right now am and that.
Um,
and I I like to attest it to,
I think because I went back once I started kind of researching you,
I like to go back and do a little research and I'm like,
fucking Joe's been with this,
this sport for the beginning.
Like you were in the back with hair is
the hair freaking interview and the guys,
yet they were during the tournament that we're finding multiple fights and nine
and you were interviewing those guys and I was like,
Damn.
Even back there,
Joe has skills.
Joe was a BS interviewing these guys.
There was no shaking behind it.
Cause I,
you know,
one thing about me,
I've gotten into comp and commentating and things like that now and I'm like,
Dang Joe,
he didn't seem nervous.
You would just like a freaking natural at it.
And the sport was just growing at that time.
There was nobody watching back then.
It was,
it wasn't as much pressure,
you know,
it wasn't like coming into it today.
Yeah.
Espn paper view,
all that deal.
It would be a lot of pressure,
but back then it was just fun.
Yeah,
it was.
It was weird man.
The first one I did was in Dothan,
Alabama and this weird like it was,
I don't know if it was a high school gym or some small auditorium,
tiny little place.
It was very weird.
They have a,
you made it look like a freaking certain little walk in the park.
I mean it was,
I was like damn chosen good at that.
Joe's been doing this shit for a while.
Well,
it's a,
it's an interesting thing to see,
you know,
to see it progress from 1997 to where it's out of 2019.
The biggest difference is not just,
uh,
the amount of eyes at accounts and amount of people that are paying attention to
the real difference is the level of athlete.
It's a,
it's a giant,
giant leap.
I can no other sport.
I don't think there's another sport from 1993 to 2019 where the athletes are
almost,
it's almost unrecognizable.
How much better the fighters are as Lilly,
you know,
now back in the day it was like,
okay,
you finished your college career,
you finished all this,
you've got to the height of whatever you know,
sport you could be,
let's start fighting.
And so guys were coming in at 28,
27 starting to learn the tricks.
Now you got freaking 10 year old kids.
Yup.
Sparring.
There's all these crazy videos like little bitty kids fighting in like Russia or
other places.
Like they're full on MMA fighting.
Yeah.
It's a totally,
that whole promotion.
I'm like,
men,
by the time these guys get to 1617,
they're going to be killers.
Yeah.
But if you go back and watch like a boxing match from like 93 a by a world
champion boxer like Marvin Hagler,
perfect example,
Marvin Hagler from the 80s could absolutely hang with w middleweights like he's,
he would fit right in with world champions today.
Absolutely.
But a UFC champ from 93 mean God,
it's just not the same.
It's not by any stretch.
It's,
it is such a,
back then it was a,
it was wild.
It was crazy,
but nobody had endurance.
And you know,
there was a few guys that had some skill and certainly our event,
Orlando v or hoists Gracie,
there was guys are really good at their individual arts,
but there was no real complete fighters yet.
Yeah.
You got the transition because it was,
everyone came in with their special scales and now it was then that was a big
thing.
I think UFC even sold that as,
oh yeah,
you got the wrestler,
the con,
the Combo,
the sambal guy and the Jujitsu guy.
And,
uh,
so that was the thing.
Everyone came in with their one skill and they put it to the test to see which
you still watch better.
It's freaking crazy.
Joe,
my first fight,
first time I ever watched a UFC fighter,
I was visiting John Jones in college freshman year.
This was our,
our,
our freshman year to freshman year.
I was visiting him cause I went to uh,
a small school,
you know,
only in William Penn University,
which is about two hours away from him.
He was at Iowa Central in Fort Dodge,
Iowa.
So I went to go spend my fall break a whole week with him just hanging out
because we had met the previous year in high school and just,
he knows his two brothers and the wrestling.
It was like,
Hey,
two brothers,
what's up man?
What are you going to school lectures like I'm bi.
I was like,
show me too as well.
We kept in touch and I went up to hang out with him.
And during that week it was a fight on someone,
like a friend of the team,
something like that invited us to come to his house and watch it and we went
over there to watch the fights.
I had never really heard of it.
I never really cared.
I was just at freshman just trying to hang out with John.
And Paul uses this room.
This was 2005 I think.
Yeah,
thousand five so it was
like first season of the ultimate fighter.
Yeah,
2005 so we got,
I think it might've been Randy couture or somewhat judges reminded,
but I forgot who was fighting and we went to the House party and watched it.
I really didn't really remember the fight.
I cause I didn't really care.
I never paid attention to it.
I never thought I would ever do something like that.
So I just washed it.
And then I remember the guy saying,
hey man,
you guys can do this.
Well why don't you guys try this?
And I was like,
me and John kind of looked at each other like,
hell,
I ain't no way are we going to do that.
I see.
You know,
wrestling is controlled,
you know,
there's rules.
W you know,
certain things you can or can't do,
there's no way we're doing that.
So we kind of laughed it off and left that day.
Never knew that I freaking,
years later I'd be doing this,
doing that,
just doing it.
Thrown the guy who many people,
including me were saying as of is a very good argument for the best welterweight
ever.
I felt like Tyron is like,
you got to give it.
There's like two,
there's legendary status,
right?
There's like Matt Hughes has legendary status from being the original.
He was one of the first wrestlers who really knew how to submit guys.
And then George St Pierre was,
of course,
many people's eyes is the greatest of all time in the welterweight division.
Went on this long run,
but I was like,
man,
when you,
if Tyron beats ooze,
mano is like,
there's a real good argument for him being number one of all time beaten.
Wonderboy beat smashing Darren tail beaten.
Damien Maia knocking out Robbie Lawler to win the title.
Absolutely.
I considered him.
I put him in that conversation.
He's in that conversation for sure.
For sure.
I put them in that conversation.
I ain't have nothing but respect for Tyron.
It was nice to see.
Yeah,
sure.
As it was.
There's a video of you and Tyrons mom and Tyron and Tarryn's mom after it is a
beautiful video.
Yeah man.
I hear jerker.
I freaking,
I let it go cause I'm one of those guys,
I never really sit and stop and smell the roses and things like that.
I always,
I always have a chip on my shoulder and I'll explain why that is.
But I always had this chip on my shoulder with everything that I do.
So I never really sit and celebrate and say,
Oh yeah,
I accomplished this or I did that or did that.
But I had known,
I known his mom.
I,
I've met her previously to the fights.
I fought in Saint Louis one time.
Man.
Of course I'd seen her several times at his fights,
but I was fighting in Saint Louis and I was there early and she was at the hotel
tire,
wasn't fighting or anything,
but she just came to the hotel.
I think she was just hanging out and I got to sit with her before,
like all the fighters even came into town.
I had to sit with her.
I think we sat for a couple of hours,
maybe three,
four hours,
just talking.
I got to know her and she was,
she was just such an angel,
but at the same time she's,
she's a gangster to like you,
you can't,
you know,
she sees everything.
And the only in the biggest thing I could compare it to is if you ever seen that
show for way backs called touched by an angel and I forget what her name is.
She's like the famous eye black actress.
And um,
do you remember that woman saying,
but don't forget her name is Maya Angelou.
It was,
it wasn't,
no,
I wasn't my Angela,
it was that late.
I mean,
she's my Angela status.
How big as she was.
Inspirational.
But that's Kinda what I compare her too.
And so we got,
we got,
you know,
I knew her and Tyra obviously wasn't who I would have chosen to take the belt
from,
but is how long could you hold yourself back?
Because being a chain,
there's a huge entire,
and send himself,
there's a huge difference between being a challenging and a champion.
Yeah.
And of course I,
I need,
I needed to have my family in that.
Yeah.
That argued I need,
I need to get them to that status to where now I'm setting my daughter up.
I'm setting everyone up for,
you know,
life better life forever.
And I couldn't continue to hold that back.
So yeah,
it was unfortunate that I had to take that from him and I kind of,
in a sense,
I felt like I was taken away from what he was doing for them.
So when I saw her walking backstage,
I just couldn't control it.
I just let,
I just let go and I just can't help but cry on her shoulders.
Disagree.
It's a great video.
What is her name was woman's actresses.
Roma.
Downey Roman,
yeah.
Yeah.
That's right there.
The video is amazing cause she's hugging you and she's telling you
congratulations and she's telling you that they're coming,
they're going to be coming for you.
So train hard.
Yeah.
And it's just like her attitude,
Matt.
It's,
it's beautiful man.
it's,
um,
it's amazing her character that she handled that.
I mean this is her baby.
Her baby just lost and lost every round and it was a,
you know,
pretty dominant victory by you and for her to treat you that way afterwards to
shows amazing character.
Yeah.
It's,
Sarah does right here.
You can see it up here.
Look at her.
She just embraces you.
Open arms.
It's all good.
It's all good baby.
Look at that.
Oh,
amazing.
That's an amazing woman right there for a couple of phone calls.
So you take it too.
Oh good.
Wow.
That's amazing man.
And even Tyron,
the way tire and hill,
it's crazy,
right?
It makes me cry.
Something in the air over here.
I've got to do it.
I got it made me cry when I saw it.
It's making me cry now.
Yeah,
man.
Um,
and in the way she treated tire and to the same thing.
I mean,
she's just,
that's,
and that,
that's kind of,
that's how my mom is to that.
So I felt such a connection to that to her because my mom has the exact same way
my mom had done the same thing to Tyron.
And um,
it just,
it was powerful man.
It was.
And because it's,
and it goes through a test to how the sport has,
how bay this sport is as well.
Yeah.
Like it's not all that's just a regular
fight.
You guys hate each other and you're fighting.
No,
this was a competition.
Yeah.
You know,
this was two men that went in there for a competition and one guy,
one and you know,
and you saw the aftermath to see the family receive each other.
People love them,
man.
They love when people put all their bullshit aside.
I mean,
you guys had a lot of trash talk at the press conferences and there was a lot of
that going on,
but that sells tickets and it's good for everybody and it's,
it's natural and normal.
But after it was over,
it was nothing but respect and it's what a lot of people think is wrong about
the trash talk of this era because there's,
this is a,
there's an error right now,
right?
We're in the trash talk error.
Absolutely.
Some people are really good at it and some people are terrible at it,
but it seems like everybody's trying me Mazda doll.
Um,
recently when he just beat Darren till it was very interesting because you know
his take on it before the fight was,
why am I,
why,
why trash talk?
Like what are we doing?
What have you,
you know,
why we're going to fight?
Like what does all this bullshit about?
Like he doesn't like it.
He was like,
I don't like where this is going.
I don't like where the sport is going.
Yeah.
I mean it was,
it's one of those things that I had to adjust to because I wasn't brought on
those principles.
I don't,
I'm not,
you know,
cause I'm not here.
Yeah.
I wasn't here for a salesman.
Like people ask me all the time,
why do you do this?
And I chose to do this,
like I'm college educated,
I can get a fucking job and I'm sitting in an office and punch numbers and all
that.
But I chose to do this because of my burning desire to compete.
That's what,
when I,
even now when I compete with guys,
I'm not competing angry.
I don't want to kill this guy.
I'm not Rah,
Rah,
Rah and all that shit.
No,
it's competition for me.
My mind is I'm going to beat you.
And which is partially which it goes to test with the how I fight and how I
compete.
I'm not like that.
This is not the only thing that I can do.
And so this error came about.
We're now everybody,
you got to talk change,
you got to sale,
you got to do this and do that.
And so do you feel any pressure to do that?
Initially,
at some point I did because it was um,
I was fighting the way I was fighting and I was dominating guys and I was
getting nowhere.
It was like,
no,
the variety.
They were kind of like just kind of putting you on the wayside.
They would always tell him,
oh,
you get a top 10 guy,
you will get a top thing guy.
But they wouldn't happen.
He was like,
oh you,
you fight this guy and you can't really argue with them because this promotion
has given you the opportunity to even really make money at all for the career
path that you've chose.
So for our,
for a while I just felt like,
man,
this is not,
I guess I just got to do this because you saw it.
The other clown Covington it,
he had to do that.
He absolutely had,
nothing has changed with the way that he fights.
He's done the exact same day since he'd been in the UFC,
but after the first couple of fighting,
no one gave a shit.
So he felt,
you know what?
No,
I'm just going to have to start doing this.
Everyone knows it's fake.
Right.
Because he just
one day woke up and started doing it.
And that's,
that's the thing now you have to do,
people try to say you have to do that,
but for me is when I'm not going to do is I'm not going to just sell my soul
just to,
Oh yeah,
I'm just trying to earn a couple of bucks because I'm not going to do that.
I'm going to do it the right way.
George did it the right wind and,
and I,
I'm a firm believer that when you do it the right way,
you will earn what you deserve.
It will come to you at some point.
I don't that,
that you have to,
uh,
really don't.
Yeah.
I mean,
Colby Covington does because I dude freaking socks.
He show each show because look,
you got to give it to him.
He did beat those aren't Joe's,
that was a big victory.
He did be Damien Maia.
That was a big victory.
Those are,
those are two legit victories over to very dangerous guys.
He did beat those guys.
He's got skill on top of the trash talk and,
but the trash talking bumped him ahead of you in line.
And a lot of us were surprised.
I was surprised.
I was surprised that he had to,
he had to do it.
And I mean it's gotten them where he has.
And I mean look what he did last two weeks ago when I fought his whole,
his whole deal was for me to create an uproar.
Right?
Get my name back in the picture.
And he did a wonderful job.
This is the one thing that I will,
I will,
I would say is that he has done a wonderful job at having people talk about
them,
whether you hate him,
which,
and even the bosses have said exact same thing is no one has done what he's
done.
No one has ever created the persona that is unanimously hated worldwide.
Like unanimously,
there's not even the hill.
Like literally it,
like those guys,
they still had fans,
you know,
that wanted to see him succeed.
Like nobody likes,
he's not safe anywhere.
No,
you don't even have to be.
There's flyweights that one hurt this guy.
So he's unanimously,
he has,
he's done a good job of creating that,
which I love and I appreciate that it's going to sell a lot of paper views.
I'm not,
I'm not a hater.
Like I give credit where credit is due.
I appreciate the fact that he has done that.
And,
and that's one day now Rashad taught me over the years,
is that you have to appreciate certain things like that.
And I,
and I do,
I always wanted this moment.
I always wanted that Connor.
It could be that,
that,
that adversary,
that Rashad and rampage,
that Hughes and,
and George St Pierre,
I like,
I always wanted that and,
and he's done a good job of creating that.
So not just an adversary in terms of like a legitimate worthy opponent,
but uh,
do that you want to fuck up.
Absolutely.
I mean,
I haven't,
I haven't been in a fight yet where it was like a malicious,
like I was maliciously trying to hurt someone.
I haven't been in that fight.
Yes,
I don't,
that's the thing it might means,
and with my mind,
my mind is strong.
I don't compete.
Oh yeah,
I'm trying to kill this guy and then you swing five punches.
You Miss,
now you're dead tired.
I don't compete like that.
This,
I'm still going to compete
as myself,
but there's going to be a letter,
extra oomph behind these,
these elbows.
Now I'm going to fillet your face with the little longer cuts.
I'm,
I'm trying to,
this one is going to be one that I really enjoy.
Well,
there was the same with could be even Connor,
what do you said?
I want to change your face when you said that,
I was like,
damn,
that's deep on want change your face.
And you saw that even when Kobi was like that is um,
because he was never out of character and it can be never was like,
oh yeah,
I'm just going to go out there and try to kill this guy.
Right.
There's a certain level,
there's a certain mentality then certain fighters have to add.
It could be you.
Is that another guy that I've seen that competes similarly to the way that I do
as far as his mind,
where it's at.
Like I don't give a shit what you do,
talk about me,
do all this,
try to distract me.
Like they tried me,
this whole come leading up to the tire and fight.
They did everything.
What are you going to do?
And then you had his,
his little psychic that looked like sideshow Bob that was was talking in doing
there is trying to distract me and this and then Colby popped up trying to
distract me.
Dad didn't change anything and that's not going to do nothing to me.
I my mind,
his own competing.
I'm going to compete to the best of my abilities and I'm going to embarrass you
and then this guy is going to be even more worth the big change in your skillset
from your first fight in the UFC to now as you're striking,
you're wrestling has always been outstanding.
Your cardio has always been excellent,
but your striking is much more fluid and much looser.
You're you,
you're much more efficient now you are always powerful.
But it seems like now everything's falling together.
Like you don't have any holes in your game anymore.
It's a different thing.
Yeah.
Joe.
Um,
I've been with my,
I've been with my same team since the start,
the same guys that have been with,
um,
for,
you know,
Glenn Robinson started arch him.
Unfortunately he passed away,
you know,
rest in peace to Glen.
Um,
when did he die?
I didn't even know he died last year.
Yeah,
he died last year.
I didn't,
yeah,
he had a heart attack man.
And uh,
it's,
it was sad.
I couldn't really believe that it happened,
you know,
but it did and I'd say he's in a better place,
but,
um,
he,
he passed and he was the,
he started all this,
you know,
him and Rashad Evans,
Rashad needed a new place when he was leaving Jackson's and uh,
and Glen was kind of like,
they got together and decided to,
to start this and Rashad Evans at the top of the game who doesn't want to train
with Rashad Evans.
And so it kind of spread like wildfire to where everyone started going down
there.
But yeah,
I,
I've been with the same guy.
Henri Hooft just came down at that time and Rufus was a striking coach.
I met with him since,
you know,
it's a phenomenal coach.
Amazing coach,
good striking coach.
So there's those Dutch fundamentals.
He has got it down.
Yeah.
And a lot of,
you know,
there's,
I've seen a lot of different coaches,
different styles.
I don't know.
You know,
I like,
I like a lot of different things.
But the thing with Henry,
he's,
he's very basic because at the end of the day when you're fucking tired and,
and you can't even hold your arms up and do certain things,
you're just going to do basic regular shit.
Yeah.
Oh,
jab to one,
two.
That's what you're going to do.
Now he's in a,
he's simple,
stupid.
Yeah.
He's very like that.
It keeps it simple.
And that was the way for me to learn it is just from the,
from the bottom up.
I just,
I learned it now.
I don't get it wrong,
Joe.
I can do some of that caution.
Like in practice I'll do a cartwheel kicks.
I'll do the all that core shit.
Yeah,
that reverse loop,
front side side,
taekwondo kick.
I can try it
ever about like moments in fights.
There are moments in fights where a fighter will do something,
but the best example is Chris Weidman versus Luke Rockhold.
Chris Weidman tries this wheel kick out of nowhere and he misses with it.
Luke gets a hold of them,
drag them to the ground and beats the shit out of him and it was a real,
Luke has a nasty top game.
His top came is crushing and he just,
he just,
Ruth was ground and pound and it changed the course of Chris's career and a lot
of ways that beating went on him and he lost the title and then he lost other
fights afterwards.
But before that he was dominating.
He had beaten Anderson twice.
He had crushed v tour.
He was a different thing and that it just,
there's these moments,
these pivotal moments in fights when someone just try something,
I mean most of the time you just get away with it.
But sometimes like in that is my go to when I tell people,
don't try some shit.
That's not your thing.
This is the best example Chris Weidman throwing that we'll kick against Luke
Rockhold yet you got to,
um,
and that's part of everything that's grouped in with fight Iq.
You have to be able to assess risk reward and certain things like that and that,
that's kind of,
at some point it was a knock on me.
He's like,
oh,
this guy had never gets out of position.
He never does any other cool shit or any of that.
You know,
it was kind of who's giving you that knock.
Fucking people come to me now,
Joe,
I listened to you say that all the time.
Yeah.
Like I was saying a long time ago,
it was like,
this guy's not fucking up.
Like he keeps running through guys and he's beating guys like a world champion
already.
Yeah.
A lot of people always kind of,
you know,
like,
oh,
he didn't do all this and not doing all that.
But the thing with me it is,
it's being able to assess when,
when I can do that,
when I,
I can't do that.
Like when I fought Rda,
I threw a freak and ax kick in the fifth round and you know,
I,
and I was,
I practiced that in practice.
I,
I catch guys with it all the time and it's just being able to assess us warm.
Yeah.
I knew that they was,
you know,
if there's an opportunity for me to start letting go.
And so I started letting go and I mean,
is it tough?
Tough dude.
Very tough.
He's a tweener hard head.
He seems like he's a tweener to like,
he's not quite a one 70 I mean,
he could beat a lot of guys that want 70 but it's almost like he should be like
one 60 or one seven five one 55 is too hard of a cut for him these days.
But the thing that's,
that's just,
that's the nature of the,
yeah,
because if we,
if we started saying,
okay,
well we're going to accommodate everybody.
It's never going to stop.
Do you think there should be more weight classes?
Well,
you don't care.
You don't get any 70 works for you.
And I still hardcore doesn't it?
It's a harder one.
91 81 80 88 [inaudible] believe it or not.
Like for most people that are listening to this,
that's on the light side.
Yeah,
no,
absolutely.
I know it is,
but the thing is,
I'm so late and I'm on 80 and I'm walking around below 6% body.
You are.
Wow.
Who Do you use to cut two for weight?
For the last couple of fights,
man,
I've been working with Clint,
Clint Wickenburg up at the Pi and Trifecta.
Yeah.
And try like Clint and Clint Trifecta food system Trifecta,
essentially,
you know,
the meal delivery,
meal prep stuff,
and they do a phenomenal job.
Phenomenal.
And Clint,
the reason I chose to go with him is I've always did it by myself.
I like to cook,
I cook for myself.
I always,
you know,
when all those fights earlier fights in the UFC,
every,
the one of my fights,
I,
he was in charge of my own diet.
I cook for myself.
I do this because I've done it so many years in wrestling all the wrong way.
I can look at myself,
I can wake up in the morning and look at myself in the mirror and tell how much
I weight and I'll be right on just because I'm so used to my body.
So I know what I can or I can't eat.
What can hold food,
what can hold water?
And it's just,
it's a discipline thing for me as well.
And so I,
so I decided,
you know what,
I'm getting higher up now.
One thing that I don't understand is that I haven't done the research is,
is what foods to eat before a certain practice at certain times to fuel me the
best to make me help,
help me feel the best because I'm getting older and things aren't the same.
They use the way they [inaudible].
I'm 31 and I'm gonna be 32 in May.
And I'm like,
man,
I just don't feel,
if you notice a lot of difference,
you know like at 24 I just fucking wake up at 6:00 AM and I can go for a
freaking five mile run like that with nothing.
Now I can't do that anymore.
Do you think that his age or do you think that is miles,
like all the hard training come?
It's a combination because 31 year in your athletic time.
Yeah,
it's a combination of both.
Because in wrestling years I,
I gotta be late forties he's wrestling years.
Am I late for us?
I mean back his reserve shot my,
you know,
my shoulders are shot,
my knee,
my knees.
Oh my God,
I've had five knee surgeries.
Jesus Christ.
So you limping.
Did you have one recently?
I just had surgery,
actually had surgery on Tuesday.
Her Suzanne had a double hernia.
Jesus,
did you fight with a double hernia?
I tore it before like five weeks before the fight and I'm,
but I don't know if it was completely,
you had a hernia and a broken foot.
Yeah.
Fucking crazy.
The funny thing is an Ali makes fun of me about this.
My manager is like all fight week.
Like if you saw me,
you would think this guy was like a Zombie.
Like I limp around,
I freaking light patches on me and I'm in a boot or sleeve and all I do all days
I go do the media rounds or whatever I need to do training,
come back and I'm just in my room either game ready on me or or something on me.
But when I walked through that door to fight the Nigerian nightmare wakes up.
I flipped a switch and a lot of people would,
would if they'd go back and look at videos of when I walk into the cage,
I said right before the case,
I'd probably say my prayer for protection and when I walk in I just freaking
don't.
If it's like a flip that switch a prayer that you say every time.
Yeah.
You have the exact same thing.
What do you say similar along those lines?
I just,
I basically just a prayer for protection,
prayer for me to be able to display the best of my abilities.
It's never,
I,
cause I'm not self,
it's just not,
I'm not getting in that prayer.
Please let me win now.
It's please protect me here so I can go back to my family safe and salad and
protect my opponent as well and give me the strength to be able to display the
best of my abilities.
And that's it.
And once I freaking walk through that door,
I'm the freaking Nigeria nightmare.
I just feel like a different person.
I am.
And you'll see it in my face.
Um,
I'm good and dandy,
but when I walk in and it goes away,
I've,
I just,
I transform into that person.
Yeah.
I think a lot of people would be surprised at how friendly and easygoing you are
outside.
People can't tell.
And that's the thing now is there's really,
I haven't,
I don't,
there's no change in me.
I'm still the same freaking guy since I haven't done anything since a fi,
nothing.
People were like asking me,
have you gone out and partied in this now with the belt and not having done
shit.
I know my daughter,
I brought her from my daughter,
but I didn't,
I didn't do anything.
I just sit on the couch,
watch TV,
go back,
made me go to the,
uh,
the shop that I liked to take my daughter to get,
get French toast.
She loves this one place.
So I take her there,
come back,
that's it.
Or maybe take her to a date night.
And the only difference is now a lot people are starting to recognize me more so
like I'm walking out the movies and people will stop me.
Hey,
can I get a picture?
You can hide a pitcher.
Yeah,
of course.
You know,
but nothing changed.
I'm the same freaking guy.
I haven't got a chance to do anything.
I had surgery last Tuesday.
I've been in bed for weeks,
so I haven't done anything,
but I don't think anything is going to change.
I'm the same guy.
And you know,
you sound like you have the perfect attitude.
Like the idea that you're having,
making a prayer to just do your best and not be hurt and not have your opponent
hurt and protect you and your opponent.
That's the,
that was a beautiful attitude.
And the fact that the way you're approaching
this,
I mean,
you just,
you're just here to compete and to do your very best,
all the,
that you,
you're free of the burden of a lot of bullshit that some people carry around
with them.
Gel.
And I was thinking about this on the way up and um,
a lot of,
a lot of those fighters,
a lot of those champions,
like after a while you,
you there,
they feel this certain pressure to,
to be able to do this or that and,
and,
and some of the examples that I gave is there's so much pressure and it's in
silver.
I almost felt like he couldn't wait to lose.
Yeah.
He was just like,
it's like a pressure the way you just want to put it down.
You imagine when Bj Penn beat them,
it was just so much want to get hired.
Is that actually,
and I feel like it was so much pressure.
George Saint Pierre ran away from the sport because of that pressure.
You know,
something for me,
I don't feel shit.
I was just,
I was just thinking,
I was like,
I don't care.
Like they look at this fight now that come in to fight.
Right.
Everyone's already bringing,
making a big deal out of it.
It's another fight for me.
I don't even think of myself as all you are the champion.
I don't care.
I just want to beat this guy up.
Do you think that you will care though when the media obligations and all that
shit happens or do you think you'd just be able to Zen your way through all that
shit?
Um,
I would be lying to say I would never care.
I would be,
I think that would be doing it an injustice.
But I feel like I go to search certain people,
like I have some of my go to people that I,
I get to the,
I call them my mentor coaches and like Rashad,
the biggest thing with her that I learned,
I talked to a shot about is Rashad was always pouring into me like,
man,
you just enjoy and enjoy the ride.
You'd be okay with that feeling because there was a certain time where I was a
little more nervous than usual.
I was,
I was nervous for Wa one I think I can't remember the fight and I was nervous.
And retailers,
I may just make friends with that feeling,
be okay with it,
make friends with the feeling of being like,
understand that it's okay to feel that way and just be okay with it.
And so that I go back to those feelings and even there was an exercise when I
was wrestling,
I was living at the Olympic training center,
I was training and I started feeling all this pressure that,
that a lot of people put on me.
All your division to guy,
you can't be Olympic champion.
You can't do this,
you can't do that.
And my coach at the time,
Brendan slayer was like,
yeah,
a lot of people may,
you know,
made put that pressure on me when I was competing to and said that,
oh you too short.
You can't beat these guys.
You can't beat [inaudible] basis.
The Tate Sattia of the,
you know,
the most famous Russian wrestler of all time.
And,
and they're saying you can't beat him.
You can't do this.
You can't do that.
And you said one exercise you should do is he'll think of all these negative
thoughts cause people start saying it in your mind.
It's you goes into your mind.
You know,
especially now when all these fans tweet shit and say stuff to you,
you read it.
If you read it,
it's in there.
And so one day he said you should do is just put all those thoughts in.
Just imagine this iVision is glass jars.
You just put them all in the jar.
Shut the lid,
grab a big sledge hammer.
You just smash it.
And it sounds silly,
but I was like,
ah.
It wasn't until a little while after I started kind of doing that.
So when I started doubting myself,
man,
can I do it?
Can I do a good,
oh man,
this guy,
he can beat me.
I mean,
what if he knocked me hard and embarrassing me in front of everyone?
Then on my snap the fuck out of it,
put it in that job,
but an HR it and smash it.
Might have fun with it,
man.
You supposed to feel like this.
Rashad said you supposed to feel like this.
Yeah man,
it's,
yeah,
and I just take a deep breath.
I smile and I just,
I snapped back in and Eddie Alvarez also is a,
someone I consider a brother and these are the guys that,
that I go to for when I started to feel down and I,
I talked to Eddie quite a few times before this last fight,
when I started feeling a little bit of pressure,
I talked to them and they just kind of,
they snap me back.
Will you wait?
Will you getting frustrated that you weren't being considered amongst the top
contenders when you were undefeated?
You dominating all these people and you were seeing it like when the,
when Wonderboy got two shots and then you know,
you saw the Damien Maia fide and these all these other fights.
Was that,
was that hard for you?
Yeah,
it was.
It was a time where I'm not gonna lie Jo.
I was like,
why the fuck am I doing this?
I'm you.
I'm going to keep fighting for 25 and 25 30 in 30 what?
What?
The thing is,
what a lot of people don't understand is they think,
oh man,
is that 15 minutes that you're out there or that 25 minutes you're out there
training and fighting and that's it.
You know you got paid tenant 10 bro.
You just did.
I just did a five month training camp to where I didn't eat right for five
months for $20,000 if you win,
if you win,
and on top of it,
it's that society so backwards nowadays to eat clean food is more expensive.
So for me to just eat clean for five months,
I'm already five 10 grand in the hole on top of it.
You've got bills coming every month.
That's not going anywhere.
Yeah.
You know,
just to train for these fights.
I've spent more than that.
And you have taken more damaged than that because that's when you really take
damage.
I'm sparring and when I fractured my foot,
that happened the last week in training,
my last barn session,
I'd kicked someone in the face.
Boom,
my foot's got,
it was a fun.
It was,
it was bad.
It was at first I just figured,
you know,
it's like more tie.
Like you kicked Shands and elbows all the time and you know,
you get the little fractures,
but that,
you know,
you work on it and has gone and a week.
But this one just wasn't going away.
The swelling kept coming back and coming back.
So I'm start freaking out my,
Oh shit.
I think I really broke something and,
and so I started freaking out and then a day or two,
three days,
four days,
I get it worked on.
I'm having a really special compression socks that I have on it at all time and
I'm icing this thing four times a day and it's not going away.
I'd wake up to swallow would be bigger.
I'm like,
Oh man,
I did damage.
So,
and then I kept walking on it and I haven't,
uh,
cause I,
I have to practice because I had to keep that weight to,
I got to keep that metabolism going.
And so I'm just like,
man,
there's no way I'm not fighting.
Like you only get an opportunity,
wants a fight call and say I'm pulling out of this.
I might not ever get a shot again.
Right.
And so I'm like,
I'm going to fight.
And there was no doubt in my mind of what I could do.
I was just,
I,
it's going to happen.
I'm already dealing with the hernia situation.
And so I'm like,
screw it.
And thinking about me is,
I have a rant in three years,
Joe.
I have,
yeah,
my knees are so bad.
I have not ran such good cardio.
What are you doing for cardio?
I,
everything I do,
I do freaking hard.
I guess I do a frigging hard,
I'm on that air dying and man shout out to my strength and conditioning coach to
Doctor Cory Peacock.
I mean,
he's also honored to,
I mean Dark Cory's uh,
we put in,
we put in some time man,
and it's not just him,
it's,
it's my coaches were Greg,
Greg Jones.
When we wrestle,
we rest.
I wrestled freaking hard and when I,
I can't do it often anymore,
but I,
I wrestle hard when I hit pains.
Yeah.
When I hit pads,
I had past hard with Henry.
Everything that I do in my mind,
I try to do it at the speed that I would want to do it in a fight and anything
greater because my whole mentality is when you get tired,
when people get tired,
that's your threshold.
That's where you're at.
So that's why your body feels like that.
Oh,
I'm tired.
There's as far as I can go.
I tried to get to that as fast as possible.
Boom.
Because then everything after that it's extra.
I just push,
push that condition and more and more and more.
So I just freaking go hard.
Everything that I do,
I do it hard.
Of course I do it smart,
but I'd do it hard.
But I haven't ran Joe and almost three years that it's crazy because one of the
most impressive things about the photos,
you never let your foot off the gas.
And in the fourth round,
I think it was when you had Tyron hurt and when you really started pouring it
on,
I was like,
okay,
he's trying to finish this fight.
How,
how much gas is he going to have left in the tank?
Because you know that sometimes when someone tries to finish someone and they
can't,
they're done.
You know,
you poured it on,
you took a couple of deep breaths then right back on him.
I'm like,
damn,
that's some serious fucking cardio.
Cij I was sprinting in my mind.
I,
I watched that back.
I was like,
what the fuck was I doing?
I was swinging like,
wow,
wild man.
Just because I saw the light at the end of the tunnel and I was like,
you know,
and um,
um,
it's like I was sprinting towards it.
But then he kept getting dimmer and dimmer.
I was like,
Oh shit,
fuck it.
We're slow down tyrants.
You're still going to get there man.
He was tough as fuck.
He ate some big shots.
People didn't really see it.
What happened was started that transition.
We were in the clinch,
I had him in a,
in a Thai clinch and I think he was trying to work on my body and I hit him with
the knee.
I hate him with another knee.
And in my mind I just remember some of the trainings that I've been through.
I've been in that situation and training and ice tray with a cosmo Alexandra,
more tie dye,
freaking amazing.
And one thing that he would show me is how more anti guys would sneak and
elbows.
And so I'm in there and I'm like,
I'm tired is not really getting out of this.
So I'm like freaking,
let me try it.
And this elbow that you throw,
it's a sideways elbow and I'm in there.
I throw a knee in and I just do the sideways up one and it doesn't look hard.
It doesn't look crazy or anything like that,
but it was like side of the head and I just felt that land and I'm trying to,
cause you got to read fast.
So I'm trying to reading them.
I'm going to try to assess them.
I'm like,
is he hurt?
Cause he kind of stumbled back.
But Tara has a very good poker face,
so he has this nonchalant face on and I'm trying to read them.
I'm like,
wait,
wait.
So I kind of fake a little fake Adam to see if he's trying to set me up for a
big shot and I fake,
he doesn't throw anything.
You keep saying it.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
So I throw a jab and I threw a uh,
uh,
right hand.
I threw it across his guard.
They hit him and he really didn't look,
didn't change.
It didn't look like he was out there.
I was like,
Oh shit,
he's hurt fricking.
Let's go.
It's go time.
And I remember I talked to Eddie Alvarez and I asked him,
why did he freak out like that when he had RDA her?
And Eddie was just like,
man,
I saw that light at the end of the tunnel and I just freaking,
I had to empty the tank and I'm like fuck it.
Empty the tank.
Let's go.
This is my moment.
Empty the tank.
So I'm throwing like a madman and Tyron has taken it all and he's tough as shit.
I'm like,
damn,
he's not going down.
And there was a couple of times he was rocked to look like he could have went
down and all I had to do is really settled back,
hit him,
went clean shots,
but I wasn't even fucking thing and about that.
I was just like,
get this Guy Outta here now.
This is what I wanted to do.
Put the stamp on it.
Let's freaking do it.
There was a hell of a barrage.
Yeah,
and I'm throwing,
I'm throwing,
I'm like
red light,
red light and the gas tank is on e it's on e,
it's on e,
which is the only reason I even shot in for a shot.
I was,
and then I heard my coach is saying take him down.
When they realized I wasn't frigging knocking them out,
they were like take it down to us
and I grabbed his leg and tried to,
but that was the thing that I can recover pretty quickly.
So you recovered very quick because it was one of those pivotal moments in a
fight where I was like,
man,
if Tyron doesn't go out here,
how much does he have left?
I knew I was,
I was scared cause I was like,
I know he knows he's probably down three to four rounds.
And I knew I was like,
I was in a sense waiting for him to just start to snap out of it.
But not soon.
One thing you,
you never really give yourself enough credit with your gaming?
With my games,
I feel like I,
um,
I put people in a,
in a trans and I like a certain to where they just no getting out of it and I,
and that,
that's Kinda been a knock on me.
People are saying,
Oh,
you're not finishing fights and I'm doing this.
You know,
you're not submit guys.
You're not knocking him out.
This is my mentality on that,
and this has been since I was a wrestling,
is they were wrestling.
You can pin guys really quick,
do slick moves and pen guys.
But then the guys would get up and say,
Oh man,
I never seen that movie before.
He caught me in this slick mood.
That's why he got me now I'm,
I'm a get him.
Next time I'm going to do that.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna get him.
And the same thing with a fire.
It's like,
man,
I had my hand down and he caught me sleeping.
So he caught me the shot.
It was a lucky shot.
He's not ever going to do that shit to me.
If I,
next time I'm going to get him or he called mood is slick submission.
I never seen that before.
I'm a train for next time he's going to um,
stop him.
My thing is even the wrestling,
what I always wanted to do as I wanted to tech fall,
guys in wrestling and tech fall.
What that means is when you're beating someone by 15 points,
you have a 15 point gap.
They stopped at match because it's basically a skunk.
Like you skunked this guy.
Like he sucked at that.
You beaten them that bad.
They had to stop it.
That is my mentality.
That is always what I strive for and in 2011 I believe,
I'm not 2011 2009 I led the Nation Division One,
two and three Nai,
whatever in tech falls.
I think at one point me and Brent Metcalf was battling like every week I would
look and see who had the most tech fault.
It was me,
be him,
be me,
him and I had the most because that's my was my goal was I wanted to say guys,
because in their mind what it says is you can't fuck with that guy.
There's,
you can't hang with him.
There was nothing.
You can do it.
He didn't.
It wasn't a quick pan of lucky pen or or this like heat destroyed you.
He just set levels apart and that's what I do even in fighting.
Now I do the exact same thing is I would much rather dominate you from start to
finish.
I want to break you.
I don't want,
I want you to think about fighting me again.
It's not you don't,
I don't want you to you.
I want you to say fuck no,
I don't.
No Shit.
No.
He beat me everywhere.
He broke me.
He took something from me because you're going to think about,
you only remember the fights you lose.
You don't like.
I've been so many guys and rest.
I can't tell you maybe 30 guys that I'd beat in wrestling.
I don't have no idea,
but the ones you lose,
you can almost tell everyone and that's what my take on it.
I want to dominate you so bad when you think about fighting me again.
You don't.
You say,
fuck that.
I'll pass on that fight.
And so people were like,
Oh man,
this guy doesn't really finish guys.
But how many guys want to fight me again?
Not a lot of them.
Do you have one loss in MMA?
Yes,
I do one loss,
right?
Yeah.
I have one loss in my second fight.
Um,
uh,
cause Sarah's,
I forget his name,
I forget his first name.
Um,
it's the Hosea.
Is it Jose?
Cause there's rather Alex.
It's Jose.
Cause his name's Jose Carstairs alleys considered rather old.
I think it's older brother.
Oh yeah.
And,
and um,
man,
it was a,
I took the final like two weeks notice or something like that because it was
like eight months in between.
I fought my first fight and I thought,
see,
that's the thing with fighters coming in MMA now this is a lesson to you guys.
Everyone feels like,
oh,
I'm just going to jump in and he's going to be peachy.
I'm beginning fights every other week.
Every other month.
No.
So I fought my first fight and I thought,
okay,
great.
My career's kickstarting,
I'm going to be doing fights.
And every so often I went through 20,
22 opponents within my first fight.
If I got the second fight.
Because now,
you know it was Google.
Now everyone all froggies it,
national champion wrestling.
I don't want to fight that because everyone wants to get to the UFC and they
figure,
oh it's the best record.
You want to be undefeated to get to the UFC.
So nobody wants to fight anyone.
That's hard.
Right?
And so of course at that point I was at wrestler,
I could take anyone down to hold them down for three rounds and when fight.
So everyone,
no one wanted that fight.
So it was months and months went by and then that fight came about.
I was just like,
shit,
I'll take it.
And I'll be honest,
I never grabbed hold before that.
I never did Jujitsu and so I figured I could rest on my way,
do all this shit like,
man,
fuck these guys,
these guys are low level guys.
You know,
look who I trained with a train.
We were shot Evans and these guys,
those guys can't touch me.
I get in a fight,
I throw a one to his legs are there.
I hit him with a one,
two boom,
boom,
double leg,
like live within 15 seconds.
Boom.
Threw him down for Mal and I'm kind of throwing punches.
I didn't really know what I was doing.
I'm throwing punches and I'm trying to elbow him and Jose,
because serious day,
I think six to 6.16 I don't,
he's well taller than me.
Long limbs.
He throws his legs.
I'm in full mount and he throws his legs around my body.
I never seen no shit like that.
Right.
My mind at that time was like,
what is,
Oh shit,
what's this shit?
I didn't know what to do.
So I'm like,
so I started kind of panicking in my mind,
I don't know what to do.
I'm like,
fucking get out,
which is what you don't do.
Right.
So I turned my body,
I'm trying to like get up and walk out,
which is what you don't do.
And so he just basically climbed up my back.
Boom.
We're not even sweating.
Yeah.
Boom.
He's on my back.
I'm standing up with a backpack on.
He's six so he has a foot on the ground,
one foot wrapped around me.
He's fighting for the Choate and I think I hold him off for another like minute
and a half.
I'm standing and I'm fighting this choke.
All the while I'm thinking like,
Oh shit,
I can't go down cause I don't know what the fuck I'm doing down there as well.
Right.
So I don't really know the defense down there.
So if I go down,
that just might make it worse.
I don't know the defense and this dude looks like he knows what he's doing
behind me.
He's got a few more,
he's out of few fights and I'm,
I'm kinda scared and I'm fighting it now.
I'm standing up,
my feet are getting heavy,
getting shaky.
I'm like,
I'm a strong guy.
What the fuck?
My feet shaking because they're starting to fill up with blood.
My adrenaline is pumping and I'm just like,
Oh shit,
I'm about to lose
Joe.
There's this moment in your mind to it.
You start to come to realization when certain things I'm like,
Oh shit,
I'm about to lose and win.
And then I start thinking about random thoughts.
And one of the thoughts that I thought thought about was before the fire,
we had a commission meeting in the bag and the commission said,
if you get choked unconscious,
you're suspended for six months.
So you can't fight for six months.
Because in my mind I'm like,
fuck this.
I'm a tough guy.
I'm you got to put me to sleep.
I ain't never tap it.
So I'm like,
if I get,
it took me eight months to get this fight and this is short notice fight.
I haven't made money in eight months.
I'm broke as shit.
I sleep and I,
I'm,
I live with Rashad,
I live with another man,
I'm broke as shit.
I have no money,
I need money.
So if I can't fight for another six months,
I have no money.
So all these thoughts are going through my mind and I hear Alex Caceres on the
other side of the cage screaming,
he is going to tap,
he's elbows out.
And I'm like,
fuck,
am I going to die?
I'm like,
fucking well played Alex.
Now I'm thinking about to happen.
Just for that shit.
Oh Man.
I just saw it going down and I'm like,
you can't be suspended for six months bro.
I know you want to be tough right now and you want to go to sleep.
What?
You can be suspended for six months,
Bro.
You have to,
you gotta.
You know you got to make money.
You're broke.
I fucking tapped Joe.
I fucking tap.
I'd never felt so,
I don't want to say emasculated if that's the word.
I never felt so like I just,
that's what I said,
like win or lose,
it takes something from you and I walked out of that fight.
I went to the back,
I paced for like maybe two,
three hours in the back,
all the fights fee finished up and I finally went to lock and got my stuff and
came out.
But I just paced back and forth and the feeling in my mind was,
I am never going to feel like this again.
I do not ever want to feel like this.
And ever since then I got a fucking gay.
I never had a game before I got to Ge.
I started training with George Santiago,
my Jujitsu coach bill to every fucking morning.
And I was like,
Brian,
sorry,
give your black belt after he came in my black Bra.
And this is the thing is I never,
I never worried about that.
I never worried about like yes,
I was freaking beaten up blue belts before I was even a white belt.
Like yeah,
cause I never did that skill trained.
Did you choose to skills?
But I knew how to grapple through certain things.
You know,
I've been grappling at a high,
high level,
but it wasn't just Jujitsu.
So he kept challenging me.
Like I was always cause I want to be that guy.
I want him to be the freaking blue belt that freaking works.
All the brown and black belts.
But he would freaking promote me.
Is I purple belt?
Because you've been training,
you trained in the [inaudible],
I'm going to promote you.
So he kept challenging me and challenging soul.
Now people knew.
I felt like all it was doing was alerting people of what to expect when they
went with me and for them to try to a really fucked me up.
And so he promoted me.
Um,
I think a couple of years ago I was a brown belt.
I proponent,
I think maybe two and a half,
three years ago.
And um,
and they promoted me to black.
He just asked me to come in and jam.
I didn't really even know.
I just felt like,
okay,
man,
he wants everyone to take pictures with the belt.
And he freaking gives me my black belt.
And another thing just floored me.
I was like,
Shit.
I never knew.
I never expected all of this.
I just wanted to fucking compete.
Right?
I just wanted to be a martial artist,
learn all this stuff and compete.
I never knew that I'd get a black belt.
I never knew that I would win the championship belt would be the best in the
world at this,
at that time.
So I never knew all that.
How much did you adjust your training,
um,
to incorporate Jujitsu?
Did you add more training sessions or did you substitute abso-freaking-lutely I
would.
What I would do is,
cause I was living with Rashad at the time,
so what I would do is I would somehow get to the gym cause we saw was traveling
a lot.
This was at the height.
He was doing a lot of different shows and stuff.
And so I would go to the gym at 7:00 AM 7:00 AM practice.
I think Monday,
Wednesdays and Fridays George would have a class and I would go and take that
class.
And then I would,
pro class was,
I think it was at nine so I would just stay at the gym while the pros came in
for the practice at nine.
So I would go through that class as well.
And then after that,
whether lift on my own strength and condition and right after that and dumb ass
me.
And that's what I'm saying,
I was 20 something at that time.
I wasn't eating in between all the sessions.
I wasn't doing any of this.
I was just freaking going,
going,
going.
So you'd eat breakfast and that was it.
I think he breakfast at that time.
If you didn't even eat breakfast,
I didn't even eat breakfast.
I would get a cold,
go to the gym,
workout.
Danny will go and roll into the next session of workout,
then roll into strangely condition or whatever I did on my own workout,
no food,
and then freaking go home,
eat a big meal,
snap,
then go back for the night session practice.
And that's how it was for a long,
long time.
And Rashad was,
would always come home and say,
hey man,
why don't you come out with me this weekend?
Let's go,
let's go out,
let's go do something.
And I was like,
man,
Oh man,
I got train on Monday,
man.
I don't want to do all that.
I want to out or should I be like,
Bro,
you got to have balance in this.
It's gotta be a balance.
And I'll just thought at that time like,
Oh fuck that.
You say that because you had the top,
you cha you the best.
So you say that my whole day was,
I'm just need to work.
I need to catch up.
I need to catch up to these guys.
I need to work.
So I was just doing over time,
over time,
over time.
But you know,
now I understand what Rashad was saying.
There has to be balanced.
Yeah.
And when did you adjust your eating?
I think,
um,
we got a strength and conditioning coach Jake,
but not but not cheat and Jake,
amazing coach man,
he woke with a lot of the Xtreme couture guys work with like Randy and those
guys back in the day.
And uh,
he's kind of started like,
you,
you got to fuel yourself.
He kind of started,
you know,
letting me in and I seek Nessa deigned by me.
I seek knowledge like I'm always,
I always want to learn.
I always want to learn whatever I can.
And I started learning like,
Oh shit.
No.
One day I was dead tired in that session.
No one had nothing left because I really didn't eat.
I had no fuel.
So I started kind of putting things in and the more and more,
like I said,
it wasn't until my last two or three fights that I started working with
Trifecta.
And Clint Wittenberg and just,
you know,
I seek knowledge.
If whenever I can get knowledge I,
I take it.
So these trifecta folks,
what kind of stuff they prepare for you?
Man,
they prepare my meals and they send it to me.
They send me the,
like I said,
I like to cook for myself.
Like a cooler,
a prepack.
Yeah,
they sent,
they send me the prepackaged shoe,
but I'm not so much into the prepackaged stuff.
Like,
you know,
I'm just throwing a microwave in need and I'm not so much like that cause I
like,
I like hot food.
I wanted to feel fresh.
So they'll send me like the package is like the protein and the chicken and the
steak or the fish and things like that.
And basically I'd taken out in my responsibility to take it off.
I think it's precooked but I take it out and I put it over the stove and make
some veggies with it and other stuff that I want with it.
And,
and I'll cook it that way.
So it seems more like a fresh meal even though it's kind of pre made.
Just from my mind.
I get it,
I get it.
So um,
do they have it broken down with a certain amount of calories for each meal?
Dependent upon what kind of working out you're doing?
Yeah,
man.
Clint,
Clint broke it down.
I give him my schedule for the week and he breaks it down like this is what you
need to eat.
Four servings of protein,
four servings of carbs,
fats and this and that.
Before your weightlifting session,
before you're sparring,
before this,
you need this amount of sugar in this amount is this amount of,
that man made a big difference because I would,
there'd be certain practice I would lift and I'm like,
fucking,
yeah,
I feel good.
I want to get out of there to where usually I hit a wall like boom,
fucking this is miserable.
Yeah.
I just,
I just grind through it.
You UFC performance institute is amazing.
It's just incredible what they did when they were just talking about building
that.
I was like,
what is this going to be like?
What do they do there,
what over the spend a lot of money.
Who knows what the fuck is going to be.
But then they took me on a tour of it and I was like,
this is literally the ultimate training facility in 10 years it is still be g
uptodate and just still be like this thing is now catching up pods.
They took me there.
I was like,
I live here.
I know you can literally live.
There were a lot of people relocated to Vegas just to make that the center of
the training.
I see Claudia Goodell,
he was down there and Francis and grinds his laundry of course.
But he trained for his last fight in France I believe.
Yeah,
his,
his last two fights.
He did it in France and um,
yeah,
we,
you know,
like that's my boy.
Like we talk all the time and um,
that's the scariest heavyweight of all time.
Like I don't understand what people are a lot of people like especially after
those last couple of fights that Derrick Lewis,
five people were like these fans,
man,
they were condemning him like this guy is.
And one of those things you just gotta give you gotta give him time to recover
from the steep a fight.
He has a psychological yeah,
got over it with,
with Curtis blades.
Yeah.
He stopped Curtis plates.
It was one of the best guys in the heavyweight division.
Curtis is a big golf course was bs and,
and even for this fight,
who wins that Keynes going,
Kay's going to do,
Katie's going to do canes,
a better version of steep pay and,
and I get it.
Like I understand Cain.
Cain is the greatest we've ever heavyweight we've ever really seen.
You know,
I mean,
you know DC right now that's an argument too,
you know.
But Cain was great but Keynes been gone for almost three years,
two years,
a long time and people are putting all this pressure on him that I expected him
to come back and be the same old cane.
Like nothing happened.
And I'm like guys like,
and not to come back,
come back and gets the scariest heavyweight we've ever seen ever,
ever.
I made us friends slip you a little bit.
The first time you lifted weights was with me.
What?
Frances never touched weights ever and,
and that's a scary thing.
You go to Africa and they,
there's this millions of guys like,
like that walking around,
I was saying that his story is like,
it's like the Kona and seen where Kobe was like pushing the wheel.
The,
he was,
he was working in a sand mine just digging in sand.
Yeah.
And becoming this tank of a man.
It's crazy.
It's obviously superior genetics on top of that because you don't get to be two
65 naturally.
I mean you have to have fantastic genetics.
He's got that too.
But his ability to land punches that just put people away with like he can graze
you and fuck you up.
Absolutely.
And they speed people.
Like I tried to,
I tried to swag with him.
I tried to with him once.
Yeah.
Once 70 white spar with him.
I mean it was just playing around and that's the day in our room.
Like everybody spotted with everybody and he loves sparring with smaller guys.
He loves it because it's,
and it's not yet because it's not,
he's not trying to hurt anyone,
but he's not trying to hurt you,
but it's just he likes working on his speech.
He's so fast.
I think he's faster than me.
Forced like,
I mean,
it's an I'm like,
is that fast?
That much power.
I mean,
if he even,
I nicely,
what I say,
if he touched anywhere near this circumference right here,
you're going to wake up and ask what happened?
Well,
that's what came was saying that he was,
he didn't remember what happened when Francis Francis apparently grazed him with
the first punch near the back of his,
of his head and Canaan remember shit after that and then clipped him with that
uppercut on the inside.
Everyone was saying like,
oh,
he hurt his knee.
That's what it happened.
No,
he got hit with a punch in,
there was a small shark punch.
All it takes with her,
but yeah.
Yeah.
What's,
what's amazing,
that steep pay weathered the storm.
That's what's amazing.
It was,
it goes,
you got to give credit to steepen and steeper weather.
The storm when Francis was convinced he was going to put steep air way after the
Overeem destruction.
I mean,
he put over him into orbit.
Yeah.
To watch that.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
And you think that striking credentials of Allister,
I mean Allister's glory,
heavyweight champion,
Strikeforce heavyweight champion,
k one grom pre.
I mean he won the three of the most prestigious titles and combat sports.
And to have Francis clip him like that was just like cheeses and that goes
through test to MMA.
This is why the sports so great.
It doesn't matter where you come from,
what you good,
it's well,
you're good at it.
It doesn't matter.
Those with those four ounce gloves and being able to wrestle him,
grapple and do all this,
everything changed.
It's an even playing field for everybody.
Yeah.
Now if he just gets his wrestling on point,
I mean he,
it's crazy that he's only been doing MMA all told for what,
five years now?
Yeah,
five,
six years.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
I mean I made this switch around the same time we had our first official UFC
fight the same time.
Wow.
Yeah.
In were was your first year of your first fight?
What was your first fight?
My first fight I think was in 2013 or 2012.
So seven years ago.
Which is crazy.
Yeah.
And how much striking and you'd done before you first fight?
Not a lot.
I mean,
I made,
the thing with me is like,
I used to watch videos when I was convinced myself,
like I was going to start doing this and this has been years in the making.
Like I was,
I coached on season 14 on the ultimate fighter with a Bisping and uh,
may have Miller,
I was may hams wrestling coach.
So,
and that was the season with Tj Dillashaw,
John Dodson,
Dennis and all these guys.
And so at that point I had started to,
uh,
shout out to Ryan Parsis man,
Dr. Parsons one who brought me in.
He was managing Ma'am at the time.
And,
um,
I love Ryan.
Yeah.
Ryan is a good dude.
Super Good Guy,
man.
I love drawing and uh,
and I was,
you know,
I'd fiddle with it.
I throw up my hands a little bit like yeah,
do this one day.
You know,
I just kind of playing around and playing around with it.
And so I love boxing.
I love watching and all that stuff.
I was like,
man,
you know,
maybe I'll do this stuff one day.
But when I watched those guys go through the ultimate fighter being here in
Vegas,
it being in Vegas and in the house,
I was like yeah,
no way.
I'm not doing that shit.
I'm never not doing it.
Even back then you were thinking I'm just going to rustle.
Yeah cause at that time I was living at the Olympic training center.
I was training for the Olympics.
I was like,
yeah,
I'm going to do this shit.
No,
it's not wise.
What was it that flipped the switch?
Rashad really were shot.
Um,
the same time I think 2011 I was still at the Olympic training center and I had
gone back and I'm just training and I was friends with King Mo.
I've known King Mo ever since I was in high school.
And funny thing is like,
man,
like we were so connected because we were from similar,
we're walking a similar paths,
king moles from like African descent.
So Am I.
And he wrestled in Texas and so was I in high school and then he's a division
two guy.
I went and division two,
he was an astro chip.
I was national champ and you know,
walk into similar paths.
I was,
I just felt connected to king more so I would always talk to him.
I looked up to those guys,
king mourn in DC and they were like,
you know,
the,
the black dudes that you look up to because they want a lot of black wrestlers.
So they was to do was that we looked up to was like,
yeah man,
Chemo.
So he has been doing it for me.
I think at that time he was the Strikeforce champion.
And so chemo calls me,
uh,
and my friend Jake Fisher,
who was a world team member at the time,
I,
Hey,
you guys want to come down to Denver and train with us.
You know me,
I'm going to train that night.
Of course I'm going to go training.
We King Moma boy,
I get to see him,
you know,
so we go down,
this is first time I've ever been starstruck in my life and this was now I've
been watching them.
It may now,
you know,
I've done the show and all these things.
So we get down there and we're an address for her mom.
You know,
I'm just thinking kick most coming in and we're going to work out with them.
It was me,
Fisher,
TC Dantzler,
and another kid named Bo and we're in the dressing room or changing and it was
Joe Warren's Jim.
We'll change Joe Warren,
Joe Warren,
man.
Bad Ass.
It's a funny dude.
Yeah.
And we're,
we're changing and all of a sudden,
you know,
I'm changing.
I'll look back.
Rashad Evans walks in the fucking dressing room.
I had a,
I had never been starstruck in my life.
I was inside.
That's
so of course
play cool.
I ain't be that dual,
you know,
I ain't no fan boy.
But I'm thinking in my motto,
Shit,
that's fucking Rashad Evans.
I just watched these dudes fight,
ran,
pays it.
And they did the ultimate fighter and all this joy like,
oh shit,
that was shot.
So we get,
we get back out and now we're training together,
we're wrestling.
And I just couldn't believe how,
you know,
good to this day.
He can fucking lie and say he took me down and didn't get one take down that
training session.
I freakin took him down several times,
ran him off the mat.
But the one thing that I could,
I was impressed by how good of a wrestler he was.
And then I started doing my research.
I said,
oh,
he actually wrestled.
He used restaurant Michigan state.
He was a two times UCO champion.
Uh,
he was a wrestler that couldn't believe how good he was.
But then after that session we sat on the Mat and we just talk.
And the keeping in mind,
my whole mind is like,
shit,
I'm talking to a superstar here.
And he was at the top of the game and I couldn't believe like we talk like we
were brothers,
like we use homeys.
I,
we've been best friends,
great guy,
man.
I mean I could,
he floored me and I was just like,
shit,
I,
that's Rashad Evans gave me his number after like give me his numbers.
Like,
Bro,
yeah,
me,
what'd you,
what you doing?
What are you going to do tonight?
I was like,
oh,
we got,
we got dropped by at to Colorado Springs.
He was like,
oh,
okay.
Well I'll be back in Denver.
I'm a hit you up,
you know,
talk like we were boys.
And of course I'm like,
it's like holding a piece of paper.
He's number on it.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
That's what shots number.
So I go home,
it's like,
do I wait two days to text him?
Do I do I,
what do I do?
I do.
Oh Shit.
There's upsides number.
It's just sitting on my desk.
I walked by it.
I look at it.
Oh good.
So,
uh,
he,
a week goes by and he frigging texted me.
He just texted me out of the blue like,
Yo,
what up man?
What's up?
I'm going to be in Denver,
this niece in our next month or something like that.
Why don't you come to train with me?
I was like,
yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
So I went and traded with him again.
Um,
just,
you know,
hung out for a little bit and then he started at night.
It became regular.
You texted me regularly like,
Hey,
I got a fight coming up by the fight,
Phil Davis,
I'm gonna Bring you down to Florida with me to train with me for two weeks.
Fuck you got fly me to Florida to try what you,
yeah,
of course.
I'm down.
So now I became like part of his training arsenal and every time that's it,
they want to show every time he would make fun of you and like,
you know,
like brothers do,
he'll poke fun at you.
You know,
you want to do MMA,
you know,
even want to do this.
You should be doing this here.
What are you over there?
Busting your button wrestling.
Like you would train all through these whole risk Leslie camp,
go all the way to Russia or wrestle a tournament.
If you won the
tournament,
you got 1500 bucks and this guy's,
I would help these guys train these guys,
go out and beat somebody up,
make 75 100,000 like what the fuck?
What am I in right now?
We're just going on.
And so he kept poking him.
He like,
man,
you know you want to do this,
you really want to do that.
So he slowly started to shift my motivation and my focus towards MMA instead of
winning that Olympic goal.
And then of course I was dealing with a lot of different injuries here and there
and tore up my knees on my back and I just,
I started to feel like my chances of winning Olympic gold has started to
diminish more and more and more.
And then I started falling in love with this sport here and there.
And then I talked with him,
talk with Chemo and chemo was just like,
man,
those straddle the fence man,
because I straddle the fence and look what happened.
Cause Chemo was supposed to be the Olympian and he was like,
I straddled the fence and look,
I lost it.
The trials and no,
I mean,
I'm in May,
so if you go and do that,
just do that.
Or I was like,
I want you to come down in Florida.
I just freaking,
I was like,
man,
that's it.
I'm done.
Wow.
Yeah.
No.
When we were talking about Cain Velasquez earlier,
Kane has had a series of catastrophic injuries,
knee injuries,
knee surgeries,
shoulder surgeries,
back surgery.
When you think about your style,
that's kind of similar to his in a lot of ways,
and that you rely on pressure,
volume,
mental toughness,
and wrestling,
all those things.
You're,
you're constantly attacking.
You're constantly bombarding your opponent with,
with technique and with pressure.
When you see that you've gone through all these surgeries and you see what
happens with a guy like Cain,
whereas body just can't compete with his mental toughness anymore.
It's almost like his book,
his mind is too strong for his body and his body just breaks.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's cause it fuck with you at all.
It's a little bit because it's,
um,
it's like,
man,
you got to switch up because you want to have longevity.
Yes.
I've had seven surgeries now.
So what's,
what have you done besides the five knee surgeries?
I've had fucking knees,
five knee surgeries and fat for meniscus on each four.
Four she two on the left,
two on a ride.
And then I've also had a microfracture,
which is probably the one of the most,
the biggest serious surgeries that I've had on my right knee now.
Is that one.
That one was ones where they try to regrow cartilage.
Yeah.
It's,
I guess the process is they make break state.
They make frank shores that condo to hopefully,
I guess you scar up,
you know,
generate a blood supply scar up.
So where it creates a little cushion but fucking it didn't work.
I feel like it set me back.
Ruined.
Yeah,
man.
Big Time.
You ever heard of a doctor Neil Riordan and a what they're doing down in Panama
with a stem cells?
No,
I'm not.
No.
I've never heard it.
I've heard of stem cells and I've,
I've actually had a round of stem cells and they're doing down in Panama.
He talked to,
do you know Tj Dillashaw?
Yeah.
Know,
talk to him about it man.
Cause he has some phenomenal actually sat my mom down there.
Yeah,
they were trying to get my mom and knee replacement surgery.
I was like,
wait,
hold on mom.
Yeah,
let's,
let's see what we can do.
So I sent her down there.
The Panama they can do he,
his office is in Dallas and I had them on with Mel Gibson.
Mel Gibson's dad when he sent them down,
there was 92 when he was in a wheelchair.
Now he's a hundred and he's walking around and wow.
According to melt.
I didn't ask,
but according to Mel,
still getting hard ons.
I didn't ask.
I didn't,
I know the way
he said.
Yeah.
I mean Mel's gone down himself and man,
I would go down if I had anything really wrong with me too.
I mean I've gotten a lot of stem cells done here in the states,
but they can do some shit down there in Panama.
They just cannot do here in terms of regulations and shit.
And they're doing phenomenal work with regrowing cartilage and meniscus and all
kinds of shit.
Yeah,
I mean I was basically a push right now while you're in recovery phase anyway,
you should really should get in contact with them.
Yeah,
for sure.
I'm going to,
I'm definitely give that a try because they've,
they've helped TJ quite a bit.
I know other fighters have gone down there as well.
Yeah,
that's something that definitely I'm going to look into because I knew,
you know,
I mean when you're dealing with bone on bone,
like I'm sure you probably are that I've been on for a long,
long time.
It's fucking hard to train a long time.
That's why it's so impressive your cardio because you can't run.
So you are you doing placebos as well?
Yeah,
I mean part of what?
Like,
like I said,
my strength and conditioning coach,
uh,
Corey,
we do a good job of adjusting to what I can or can't do.
And you know,
obviously back squats are not the biggest,
the best thing for me to be doing.
So we didn't modify.
We do different types of squats and things like that and we still get pretty
good results.
Do you do any swimming?
Yeah,
I play in the water a lot too.
And that that's,
I do a lot of footwork stuff in the Lauder because it takes a lot of pressure
off.
I was forced like I can't,
I mean I'm not going to go in here and do backstrokes and all this crazy
swimming techniques,
but you know,
I get in there to get that workout pool,
dig into these friends.
You said your shoulders are fucking with you two shoulders or,
I mean I'm a wrestler,
you know,
shoulder's always gonna be banged up,
but I haven't,
I've been fortunate,
no surgeries there yet.
But um,
yeah,
knees.
I've had surgeries five and then I tore this my index finger,
that tendon right there.
And I tore that my junior year in college and I tore that.
I had surgery with that to replace that repair that and then now this freaking
whole apparatus that I have going on in my lower abdomen Mesh.
They do bro.
I,
um,
I did a little bit,
I told them cause they didn't,
the doc didn't want to work with Mesh that well cause he said that,
you know,
there's good and bad results with the match.
You know,
I got this freaking drain coming out of me.
Right.
Oh Shit.
That,
oh my goodness.
Look at that plus and stuff.
It was blood like it was basically the blood.
It's like a vacuum.
I think that's what they call it,
drain and blunt.
But now it's uh,
it's coming down.
It's not that much blood coming out of there.
And how long ago was that?
Tuesday I got wow.
So yeah,
I've been,
I have to walk around and maneuver,
wrote this thing in shoes.
And the worst thing is the burning,
cause it's obviously sticking out of a hole.
There's a hole in me.
So the burning sensation around it.
The third day I told the physical therapist the,
I was like,
Yo,
I almost cut the shit off of it.
Says
because I'm not big into the painkillers.
Right,
right know.
So I'll take it maybe the day after I'll take it.
And,
you know,
maybe,
but they just don't do much for me.
It doesn't kill the paint.
I'm like,
why do they call these painkillers?
It doesn't kill the pain.
It does.
It makes me a little loopy.
It makes me stupid as fuck.
I don't know either saw,
I just have a bag of m and I just,
I don't want to do anything.
What about CBD?
Do you use?
Uh,
I do man.
Shout out to all,
I'm sponsored by a love hemp.
Beautiful love hemp is a UK companies.
Yeah.
Amazing.
They're doing some really,
really big things and I'm big into like the oil I have and I have the rob and I
both,
I use those a lot.
So that's in my repertoire.
Yeah,
that's huge for anybody that's experiencing any kind of inflammation plus for
general anxiety and overall health.
CBD is fantastic.
Yeah.
No psychoactive effects too,
you know,
cause that's the,
that's the,
that's the freaking stigma behind it.
Like,
oh,
it's marijuana,
it's weed.
And we were talking about marijuana before the podcast.
Like,
oh,
I do it.
I'm like,
I'm coming on.
[inaudible] should I smoke?
No,
no.
We watch you watch,
you loose in here.
I want you to go into a hole.
The problem is like when people don't get high and then they get high in a
pressure situation like this,
you're just like,
yeah,
go into that tunnel.
You're like,
oh my God.
Yeah.
It's um,
I've,
I've tried,
I've smoked four times in my life know how did it go?
Ah,
not good.
I mean,
the first time it was my 24th birthday,
24th birthday,
uh,
I smoked with,
who has a couple of friends of mine at the Olympic Training Center and they
didn't do anything cause I don't even know how to,
I don't know how to hit the blind.
I don't know.
I didn't oil.
Yeah.
So it's like,
man,
this stuff don't affect me dying and do this.
So,
so,
so I did not even say,
screw that and you want to do it again.
And then the next time was the year after with Jason Miller,
my hand Miller.
Oh.
May Have knows how to hit that.
We had,
I was it,
we were doing,
it was doing the ultimate fighter when we were doing that.
And um,
one thing we do at night is a lot of people expect like,
man,
when he's not on his hat,
super cool guy.
He's an amazing
dude.
I mean there's always like kind of like being around Mike Tyson and there's
always like,
yeah,
there's always that edge to where you're in the room with the,
with the fricking lion.
Like,
yeah,
he's been the coolest lion ever.
But you still know what the fucking line and may hams like that you're in the
room,
everything's cool.
But he still has,
he can snap at any moment.
So we're sitting on the balcony at night and we'll just talk and he would just
talk about these.
And the weird thing about mayhem is he always watched,
like he watched nothing but like smart shit.
Like the news,
like the Kobe or report or like things like that,
you know,
he wouldn't watch,
I would think he'd watch like nine oh two one o
or rigor,
the shows like that.
Like,
no man,
he,
you know,
he was very intelligent guy who would just sit there and talk at night.
And um,
he gave me that nickname that night too.
And freaking,
he's like,
Bro,
you first name starts with a k,
your last name is Bush,
man.
Oops,
I'm going to fricking call you kush.
I'm calling you coach
fricking the next day on set,
everyone calls me Kush till this day people call me Kush,
the Nigerian night free.
And at that time it wasn't born yet.
You know the name wasn't there cause that to start fighting yet.
But so I've had nicknames all through all throughout my life,
my career,
which is the whole been aspirin shit that he's trying to run with it though.
Is he crying you Marty,
Marty from the protocol.
The Marty from Nebraska.
See this is the thing is when I started wrestling,
I started in high school.
My coach was this big marine dude,
you know,
it was in shape bus.
Kurt.
Why Dude?
And he comes up to me,
I'm five foot two a hundred pounds soaking wet.
And he's like,
oh.
He's like,
what's your,
what's your name,
kid?
I tell him buddy,
I don't even think he paid attention.
And he's like,
man,
what'd you to try to wrestling?
I'd never heard of wrestling.
All I've heard is WWE.
I'm like,
Nah man.
I try and get hit with chairs
stuff.
I try to do that shit.
Ah,
okay.
We'll give it a shot.
And our assistant wrestling coach was the assistant football coach,
so they kinda would poke at me.
Yeah,
you come try wrestling,
come try wrestling.
I'll do the football season.
Then the next year I freaking,
I not it up and I freaking just sign up for wrestling.
I went in and,
um,
he looks at these reason role,
she calling names and he goes,
Kamar rude.
Who the fuck?
Who the fuck is this kid?
And uh,
as me coach,
and he's like,
that's your name.
He's like,
I'm not saying that because my whole full name is [inaudible] Kumar routine
Kamora dean.
And he's like,
I'm not going to say that.
Like,
C'mon commodity.
And in Kamar mark,
I'm going to call you Marty.
And I'm just like,
yeah,
sure.
Coats.
I'm,
I'm fucking five foot,
300 pounds.
I'm just scared of this guy.
And I'm like,
sure,
let me your kid,
you don't care.
You're going to have nicknames all grown up.
So why does it UFC shorten your name to come on?
No,
I that's,
that's what my parents called me.
Oh yeah.
My parents call me tomorrow,
but the full,
it was like my,
my name is Joseph.
My parents call me Jo Jo.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So the,
you know,
so that it's,
it's Camaro.
That's when my parents was calling me.
That's what I call myself.
Okay.
You know,
but my full name is Joseph and you knows Camorra Dean.
So,
um,
so Marti,
yeah.
He's like,
I'm gonna call you Marty.
So fucking online now the whole team is calling me Marty
and you know,
people are so fucked,
man.
I love those names.
I love that coach,
man.
He essentially change,
essentially changed my life.
It changed the course of my life.
That is such a funny thing though to do and call you.
Marty close starts with a totally different letter.
I know,
but it seems to work.
It works so well
to where,
um,
this is the thing about nicknames.
If you fucking,
if you're a guy like just a regular average guy,
you suck.
Your name dies with you,
you move on on care,
you know,
but if you're doing something incredible,
something spectacular that named lives are so now Marty went from just now
everyone on the team call me Marty to where people know about the wrestling
around the wrestling cert kit,
you know,
in high school or calling me Marty or that Marty guy that did kids good.
And then our college coaches are calling like,
oh,
I want to recruit this kid.
You know,
this Kamari and kid.
And he's like,
oh Marty.
So now they,
oh no,
me as Marty.
So now I go to college and the coach is calling me Marty,
and now the college team is calling me Marty.
Now here's the situation.
But this whole Ben asks,
one thing is like I just mentioned,
if I was just a regular guy whose son,
no one cares.
No one knows your name,
you die out.
But because I made waves like I was that Marty kid that wrestled at Nebraska
that's beaten the shit out of everyone.
Division One,
two,
three,
Nai Juko does it matter?
Ben knows of me.
So you know,
he's trying to cling on as something to bring it back.
Like oh this is funny.
I'm trying to hide from it.
No,
no.
I really was Marty from Nebraska and everyone's at all as Marty from Nebraska.
I really was that guy.
So you know,
for him to bring it up,
I thought it was silly.
But you know these fans,
Fans wanna they,
cause Ben is a representative of the trolls.
Like most of the trolls look like Ben asked if I could give you any info.
That's hilarious.
If I can give you any advice,
please don't pay attention.
I don't pay attention to comments.
You know that glass jar?
Yeah.
Once you smashed that,
scientists don't even put anything in there anymore,
man.
Don't,
nothing.
I,
and I've,
I've heard you say that so times like I um,
when I started paying attention to the show,
I started watching the show and I watched the one you did with Tyron when Tyron
was up here and,
and you so right.
Like some,
cause that's the one thing that I always felt like so unfair about Tyron is a
lot of people just gave him shit because,
and I think it started because he didn't take that belt.
They didn't dethrones George San Pierre.
So I,
I think a lot of it stemmed from that.
I know about that man.
I know it does it,
it can be stopped.
Robbie Lawler if that didn't give him,
I understand but,
but George Saint Pierre still looping around is that there was a big champion
but sort of not because he retired.
He said I'm going to step away.
Yeah.
But he,
he stepped away.
Yes.
I understand.
For you of being the,
obviously you know so much about the sport,
you being in the sport for so long.
Yes.
But for these fickle fans don't know shit.
That's why he can't listen to all they know is it's George Saint Pierre Verse.
Epi was a champion.
He never lost Isabelle.
So I felt like Tyron and forgot his fair share necessarily.
I feel like the same because,
because he never took the belt from George and he always wanted the Wonderboy
fights.
I think the Wonderboy fights were so fucking hard.
Yeah.
But even even then before that,
fight Wonderboy,
that way,
that is the way you fight that guy.
Yes.
You know,
unless you know someone like me comes in and doesn't eat,
what would you do it?
What would you do?
I don't know.
I just do.
I just do me cause he's still in the mix.
How would you do me?
You know,
I will eventually get ahold of them.
I will eventually break him and you know,
eventually make it look easy and then people are going to just complain.
So it is what it is.
Yeah.
The,
the,
the problem with him is he's so difficult to get close to me.
He's a different guy because his style so different,
he'll stand totally sideways on you.
His hands will be down and he can wrestle.
I mean in terms of takedown defense,
he's got good take down defense and his strikes come from fucking weird angles,
man.
He moves like a snake.
Like he bends at the waist,
then pops forward watching kickbox and Africa and well,
but I saw that,
you know,
I knew it was a problem when he threw that one kick that came over the fucking
shoulder and smacked question mark.
It was weird isn't off the front leg.
He's very good with it.
He just,
you don't even know what's going on.
He think maybe he's going to kick you in the body.
Yep.
Surround,
surround comes over the top and it smacks you in the Fed.
Nah,
he's very talented.
Like I like wondering what law,
you know,
but like I just felt like I saw that show at I and you said the exact same thing
to them and that's what I said too.
And that's what I was thinking too.
But it is your centered none because partially what I,
I got into this and why,
why I appreciate the platform that I have right now is the fact that you can
affect so many people at such a rapid amount of time because there's been an
instance to where,
I don't know if you ever remember that movie,
what women want and Mel Gibson,
Mel Gibson,
I didn't watch it and basically he could hear women's thoughts and things like
that.
And then there was a,
there was a girl in the office in the movie
who she was planning to kill herself because no one really paid attention to
her.
She's like,
no one would care.
And she's walked around with books.
I applied for a job,
everyone blew me off.
No one cares.
I'm going to kill myself this day.
So she was planning to kill herself and he heard her because he could hear what
women think.
He heard a thoughts,
but initially didn't really pay attention to it until later on he realized she
was missing from the office and then he like ran to go find her and essentially
saved her life.
But my thing is,
and that's a quote that I live by with great power comes great responsibility.
Like what if there's someone that's dealing with something at a certain time and
yes,
I didn't ask to be put in that position,
but they,
you know,
and they just decided,
oh,
I'm just going to reach out.
I'll send a message before I kill myself this day.
No one's going to respond and one's going to care.
And I happened to read that message and talk to that kid off the ledge and that
kid becomes fucking,
you know,
wins the Nobel peace prize later on in life.
Like that's a responsibility that I have that I didn't,
I didn't put that on myself,
but that I have with the gift that I've been blessed with to touch so many
people.
And so how am I going to know that if I never read any of my messages or
comments and things like that?
Yes,
of course.
I,
you know,
all the negative ones.
Yeah.
Blow and blow it up.
Well,
how do I know it's negative if I don't read it?
You all,
so that's what I'm saying.
It's easier said than done.
It's like I read this.
If now what I do is I read,
if I even feel like it's getting negative dilly,
dilly,
I can't read them all.
Cause after that fight fucking I got thousands,
I'm sure.
So you know,
I can't read them all.
But every now and again when I'm bored enough and I have time,
like I'll read some of it because sometimes it is good,
good things,
but you know,
most of the time it's easy things
there.
You know I shit you not.
And there was a,
yesterday I posted a picture,
there was one guy that responded to maybe 40 to 50 people are negative shit.
Oh yeah,
we'll give out as an Instagram do you are going to die in this.
And you know what I did is I just blocked him.
It's like,
Oh man,
you're going to get knocked the fuck out.
You're going to do this.
I'm just like,
oh my God.
Like Bro,
really?
You literally took your dead time out of your day.
We sit here today,
just knocked and he saw your face.
Imagine.
Oh my God,
I wish.
I wish we could do that.
And he answered it gets who answers the door is bad ass grin.
He looks like
just fucking belly out like this.
Is there traded a day in his life.
What did you think?
You have the Robbie Lawler fight with Ben.
Oh Man.
Like I mean,
come on.
They got to run that back.
I was thinking when it was over,
the herb dean made a mistake,
but the more I watched it,
the more I think he didn't.
I think what happened was,
I think Robbie went out.
I think his arm dropped and I think when herb came over,
this is what Dan says too,
that he loosened up the choke a little bit and Robbie came back to it and Robbie
probably doesn't even know because Robbie's such a fucking savage.
She probably didn't even know he went out.
Yeah,
but okay then.
Yeah.
This is the argument and this is why it has to be ran back.
There's a good argument.
He said that,
you know,
this is a argument because first of all,
when when,
when Robbie ran that truck through Ben's face like he was at,
it's funny way of putting it.
He was out and welcome.
He recovered.
I mean he got hit with some fucking bombs,
but we're freaking wrestlers.
The one thing about wrestlers at the elite level is you can be out of it,
but your body will naturally go through certain motions,
grab a leg,
pull up,
probably was bombing on him.
Robby ran a Mack truck through his face like that was undecided.
Like pull that fight up truck through his face.
Like I feel like Robbie knocked him out,
woke him up,
knock him out.
Like Robby was just savage mode and,
and that's the one thing about Ra and no one Robin now,
because I trained with him,
is it Robert is such a different guy.
Like he,
he's,
well he,
you know,
the way handle handled the loss was so classy,
but that's Robbie man.
That's the explanation.
This is the thing with the explanation is you can argue that fight should have
been stopped when Robbie was know bombing on him.
You could argue that for sure.
But at the same time a Rabi explains it is Robbie has so much experience and it
was a bulldog.
It's like big brother choke.
So you know,
it could have not been doing anything but Robbie explained it as I put my hand
down because this wasn't doing shit each chill,
relax,
you know,
cause I don't want to panic.
Robbie has that much experience.
He should know what to do with it.
Maybe that's what he was doing.
Good.
But the way he put his arm down,
it looked like it was owl.
But then when rob,
when herb dean came to check on him while he was giving a thumbs,
thumbs up,
herb dean didn't really give him a chance to put the thumbs up and stops the
fight right then and there.
But as far as,
oh,
I loosened to choke.
That's why he came to know was a fucking legal.
Loosen the choke until this,
the ref pulls you off of him or you pop his head off.
He said it lightened up when herb came over because he thought that herb was
going to stop the fight cause he felt Robbie go limp.
You don't lighten up because you think someone's going to stop a fight.
You don't.
You don't lie.
You know because you think you squeezed harder because you want to make him stop
the fight.
I see a point in also,
there is a difference between squeezing someone out and beaten on them when the
referees coming,
if the referee comes and you stop punching because that's one,
that's one thing,
but you don't,
you have him in a bolt ear here in survival mode.
You can't like really you were in survival mode,
but boltok chokes are legit.
I mean they really do work.
Yeah,
I'm not going,
I'm not going to let you know.
Listen,
I'm not going to say it's lost the title.
Yeah.
Lips.
I'm not going say it and caught him in a bulldog choke.
Remember that?
Yeah.
I'm not going to say that.
Don't work.
I'm not going to,
you know,
he could've been out.
He could have knocked me out,
but the only way to to put that all to raz is to run it back.
But what,
what kind of sucks is when you're like,
no,
I pass.
I,
I mean I might pass.
What do you what?
Come on Bro.
Relax.
He said he didn't want to fight him in the first place.
Well,
no,
Shit.
Yeah,
we'll probably looks sensational.
Robbie looked like a fucking Saturday.
We're going to watch it right now.
Here we go.
We're going to watch this shit.
Then look at the body.
You laughing.
Come on and say
that's the ideal combat sports body.
Look at this.
But it is amazing that he's able to get ahold of Robbie.
I was stunned.
No,
I knew he was going to get ahold of rob right away.
They sat out.
Crazy savage moon.
Boom.
Not eat that.
Eat that.
He's a big shot,
Huh?
Go to sleep.
I'm out.
Otis.
Geeky still there.
He's no evidence that these out.
See the hands?
No,
no,
I don't think so.
I think he's eating his shot and then he's got the clinch.
I don't think he was ever out.
No,
there were certain moments he was.
He was,
well he definitely ate some big shots,
but I don't think there's any evidence at all to me was out.
This is the thing,
like ban is toughest shit though.
Like I give credit where credit is tough as hell.
Man.
He's tough as hell and right now he's just drunk driving right now.
He jumped out of it and he's a one truck drive.
The funny way to put it,
he's just driving right.
And I look at this drunk driving but now Robbie books free.
See I forget the actual strength scramble that led to the bulldog choke.
Yeah.
It happens from when Robbie tries to get up cause he does get to take to,
oh look,
he's drunk driving.
Oh my God man.
A lot of blood.
You caught him with a nasty lefthand there.
Yeah.
Like we're just looking for,
we're looking for a bomb and Ben is just moving forward like a Zombie.
He grabs a hold of them was interesting.
Interesting that he was able to grab a hold of them because I would've thought
that Robert would have avoided that shit at all costs.
But that that's why he's able to grab a hold of someone and he's when someone is
so you know,
worried about you grabbing them and they each kind of shuts them down a little
bit.
Good needs of the body there by Robbie.
Yeah.
That's the thing you did in the tire and fight those fucking body shots.
Good Lord.
I was trying to take that paper home.
You hit him with so many right hands to the body.
So here we see Ben Clinch.
Yeah,
he's doing a good job here is trying to,
he's trying to come to where he's trying to,
you know,
recover,
doing a good job,
keeping it close.
Now you can get really get hit with big shots,
you know.
And he does get the take down at some point.
Yeah.
I do not remember how it happened or what was it?
Here it is.
He reaches down.
So he's got them in the clinch here.
He's got the under hook and the left side,
and so some were okay.
He grabs the leg.
I do.
It was this interesting,
I don't remember this.
All I remember is the open exchange and then the final exchange.
Yeah,
he see right now he's trying to go 201 yes.
Good job.
So he's got the single single Robbie doing a good job.
Now he's got the hands class together.
It's amazing to me how good of a wrestle he is.
I'm going to be honest with you that it's just funky because it's like not
really muscles there.
It's just like Gumby,
but you know,
it's not going anywhere,
but it's tricky.
Very tricky.
Yeah.
Very,
very sneaky.
Very chicken down.
And now Robbie's on his back.
He's,
it's,
yeah.
Sort of in talking to you.
Okay.
So now he's got an arm,
typical robberies.
He Robbie's just chilling.
Boom.
He started circles.
Owl.
He's got the headlock.
Okay.
Now he's got the headlock,
and now watch that.
Right.
See this position.
Yeah,
but see this position,
she,
Robbie puts it down.
Yeah,
it's moving.
Yeah.
Nope.
Yup.
See,
changed my mind again.
Yeah.
I like to see that's,
that's what's tricky about that since that's what's tricky about that.
I changed my mind again.
I don't think he was out.
No,
see,
because you first get up to just to the arm going limp because the thing about
the arm going limp is the way it went.
Limp looked.
It really looked like he was okay.
But this is it.
This is what I'm saying right here is initially in the situation.
Wait,
wait till he turns.
Wait till he turns when,
right.
Right.
Wait to pull his arms out.
Boom.
Right here.
See,
this is uncomfortable.
This is very uncomfortable.
Like you're spread out here and the guy's choking on your neck.
You got to bring one down to relieve pressure.
Either that one down or take this one inside.
Yeah,
he was.
So Robbie did the approach right thing or the arm fell down whether he was out.
So man,
it,
it's a tough goal man.
One more time.
Let me see.
That arm drops his back it up just a little bit here.
So the way it drops,
he'd like,
nobody moves immediately.
Boom.
So hard to know.
Yeah,
he might,
he has been dealing with the choke.
Yup.
And that changed my mind.
And it's a typical Robbie man cause Robbie says,
Robby says,
man,
I experience,
he said,
man,
I knew that that was uncomfortable.
So I just put my arm down,
chillin.
Yeah,
that's,
and that's it.
No,
I'm on your side.
Fuck Bro.
There's only one.
You have to run that back.
I would,
I would say so.
But the,
how much can the UFC tell him what to do?
Like what could the UFC,
what he said to Ben Aspirin,
listen,
this fight has to happen again.
That's like that's the sport we're hid.
UFC,
the judge,
the jury.
And if they want the execution,
what did it Ben,
what did a Dana white say after the fight?
He said he wanted Ben to fight him again,
right?
Yeah.
Dana said we're going to run that back.
And Ben's like not pass man.
I Dunno Robbie.
He's like,
yeah,
we gotta do it again.
Well,
I know Robbie was England for a fight with Darren till,
but after Mazda all starch staring until,
which was nasty.
Nasty.
People sleep on Mazda though.
They do or do not know why I don't understand it.
Go back and watch those backyard fights.
That guy's been going at it a long time.
Hey Man.
And he,
man,
that's he to better both backyard right now and that he just had again this
weekend.
Yeah,
I know.
That was crazy.
It's about um,
you know,
you can't just talk like nowadays it's this error.
You could just say whatever you feel like you could say what you want because
he's social media.
You want to get fans on your side and this and that.
And he just happened to say it to the wrong guy at the wrong time.
Like that.
That's the situation.
And you did it backstage to mass.
It don't give a fuck.
Like it's mutual.
I think I,
I think it's a mutual respect with me and mass with all I like I respect him,
you know?
I mean if we have to fight,
we have to fight one day.
But you know like we feel the same when it's like if you're going to talk shit
online when I see you keep the same energy.
Like when I saw Ben Astrin backstage,
the only thing that stopped me from pushing his head through that wall back
there,
it was the fact that I almost blacked out blacktop when I was walking towards
him.
Then I realize Dana was right behind.
So you were angry.
It wasn't that I was angry.
It was the fact that Bro,
like if you're,
you're,
you came at me online like you had a problem with me.
Like you started talking mad shit to me.
Like you had a problem like saying things,
putting up means and all of this.
To me that means like you have a problem.
I don't know what I did to you,
but you've got a problem with me.
So when I see you now,
like I want you to still have that same energy.
Don't just act like we're cool.
Like what's up bro?
Yo,
we want to hug it out.
Don't look like that.
Act like you still have the problem.
Same problem.
But do you think he's just trying to market?
I mean Ben,
not ever,
but that's,
that's fun anger.
That's attitude towards them.
But that's what I'm saying.
That's the thing.
Like people are kind of letting them off with certain things now.
Now what happens if mass full doll would have started him like that backstage
because he did talk shit.
You got to what happened if that was him?
Mass Woodall starts like that.
What happens?
Yeah.
You know,
so that,
that was my thing is I,
when I saw him backstage,
I almost wanted to push his head through the wall,
but not really like Dennis behind me.
Brian's bye [inaudible] now in,
uh,
in,
in England because they don't like that shit over there.
I don't know.
But I think he got away Scot free.
Really?
I think I haven't heard anything and everything's fine.
He's in the backyard.
That's hilarious.
If that's the case,
cause that's the salt.
Yeah.
But I mean,
I guess it's hard.
It's hard.
It's hard to say a salt when you're dealing with UFC fighter.
Right.
And so hard.
He played basketball off the court.
Absolutely.
You know,
it's hard to say that.
So it's a tricky,
tricky situation.
But he struck them out in the parking lot and yeah,
I have to baseball but I think David and then Dana put out a statement saying
that that can't happen anymore.
We got to do a better,
something like that.
We should do a better job of having security around two separate guys.
They did it on my,
they
didn't let me near been aspirin or a cold dead.
Yeah.
There was one time,
not before this fight,
but before a previous fight where you were backstage.
It was actually,
was it a press conference?
It was a press conference.
And you were trying to talk to Colby like what's up man?
Shit.
Yeah I was scheduled to fight Santiago ponds in the bones.
That's right.
And we were doing a big press conference and they happened to have like,
I didn't even know he was there cause they hit,
they had them hidden away the whole time.
It wasn't until we were going to get on the bus to go to the press conference.
He came downstairs like we were all meeting in the lobby and I saw him and right
away I told him I,
I don't know what it is.
I just,
I stopped my boy and I just started your blood.
My blood just started bawling.
I started.to a read.
I was,
I read man,
this is not gonna work.
This is not a word you all,
you gotta move and reuse.
We're getting them right now.
We're moving from and read,
but it puts them in a different car and every,
all the other fighters right together.
And this is what I mean,
he's already isolated.
That's so,
so we get there,
but we have to line up to walk out.
So he's lined up and he just happened to be my vicinity and Isaiah's free.
I was trying,
I was like,
yeah,
I'm not going to say at night and I'm not going to say I'm not going to say
nine.
I just look at him.
Yo,
I see you was talking all that shit online now.
Now we in person.
You can't talk.
What's up with all that shit you was talking online,
you thought she was tough.
What?
What's up with that was that tough guy now and he's just like,
I think he was reading his lines like what he was going to say when he got out
there and press called me,
they use this like weed and he heard me and he's like shit,
I don't want to say nothing.
Shit.
I could get my ass whooped right here
and I could set all those thoughts was contemplating and Whitaker was standing
next to him and Whitaker does one of these joint like look wrote fuck this new
talk it too.
Cause I had to watch the video over and over where it could look bad.
Like he ain't talking to me and then saw Colby was like,
oh he's talking to Kolby so Whitaker just kindly slid off to the side and I'm
get,
I'm like,
what's up with all that shit you was talking.
And then he's like quiet,
quiet.
And then he sees the security kind of cause then they heard me and security kind
of walks.
I didn't even know there was a camera back there.
Uh,
and then security walks up and security,
he's like,
Yo,
you don't know.
No,
we don't need this.
We don't need this.
And this was,
uh,
what Prescott,
could be,
was about to fight.
This was after that Connor could be bus situation.
Yes.
And so they're like,
Yo,
we don't need this this week.
We don't need this.
And now once this security,
he goes,
stick,
stick to stick to a network television junior stick to this boy.
You not?
I'm like,
no,
don't worry.
Tell him.
And what does that mean?
Because I guess he was fighting in his first fight on now on paper view.
Oh,
but this is the thing.
You were on Fox.
But this is the thing is he had never had line of car to this day.
I don't think he's ever headlined the card.
Yeah,
no,
he had line of card did he?
And not a paper view,
but um,
when he,
when he fought,
um,
Hofeld dos Anjos yeah.
That was the main thing.
It wasn't it.
That was a co main event under a Yoel Romero and Whitaker.
Oh,
Chicago.
He's never headlined a card.
Never,
never headlined a card.
Well you might be right.
And I think it about it.
Yeah.
And he's like,
he's like stick to network.
I'm like fuck,
I'm fucking like Bro,
you never done shit.
And so he's trying to play that angle and all this and that.
And I was just saying you were right.
Look at that.
What do you and Romero too?
Yeah,
he's never had mine was Covington.
He followed Damien Maia on the undercard.
Well I think it was like on the main card,
but even seeing him Pumpkin,
Michael Jackson,
tremendous fight.
No,
it's man,
it,
I was impressed with him.
Pete and dos Anjos I really was.
I thought that was impressive.
And what way?
Well because he beat dos Anjos yet because the name yeah,
that I give that.
Yeah,
you beat Rda.
Rda is a name like that.
He was tough as hell.
Former champion.
Yes.
But I already get one rounds,
audio one fourth and fifth round audio is taking him down like you saw that
already took them down numerous times.
Well,
he didn't let me just clarify it.
He didn't beat him as impressive as you did.
That's true.
Yeah.
I shut up,
man.
I don't really care.
I don't really care about all that stuff.
Like man,
it's my thing is overall the knowledge all like I've been on such a journey,
man,
my whole life I've been on such a journey.
I've dealt with so many things that I internalize man,
and now I don't really talk about.
So I don't really care what all these guys are doing,
man.
I've had a hard life.
Not the hardest.
I'm not saying it's the hardest life,
but I've had,
I've had a lot of things happened to me in life to where I'm just saying I'm at
this point in life where a man I,
I don't,
I don't want to deal with all the hate.
I don't want to deal with all these other stuff.
I understand it's going to come with the sport that we do.
But man,
I got bigger shit going on in my mind that I haven't worried about rather than
all of that little things.
Man.
Good for you.
That's like I said,
your attitude in so many ways is so good that you're,
you're,
you're there to compete,
that you're,
you're there to do your best.
You're not getting caught up in bullshit and petty nonsense and you know,
you're just putting pressure on yourself to be the best you could possibly be.
That's,
that's where,
that's where you see real greatness.
Yeah.
And I mean like,
I like Tyron was,
man,
there's a,
there's this thing too where you,
you get to a point where you have to,
you're the guy who has to provide,
you're the guy who asked to hold up.
And it's not,
not necessarily people saying you have to do it,
but you,
you,
you feel that sense of responsibility,
you know?
And,
and in,
in my family,
I,
I felt that I feel that sense of responsibility.
Like there's one that your family when you were growing up.
Yeah.
You know,
like I like when I say I come from humble beginnings,
all like being raised in Nigeria.
Like,
and it wasn't like the village village where we lived in huts and we had a
house,
but it wasn't really,
we didn't have plumbing,
you know,
we had to go to the well or get water.
We electricity was ray.
That's a scarce thing,
you know,
and it to where we,
even when we came here,
when we immigrated here yet life got a lot better.
How old were you when you came here?
About eight years old.
And it was hard to adjust to the school system,
you know,
because kids will,
kids,
his kids are mean.
I had to talk with the funny accent and kids would tell you,
hey,
why don't you say this to the teachers?
Hey,
hey bitch,
call it.
And I was always in the principal's office because I had no idea what that means
and things like that.
So kids would curl.
I had to,
I,
you know,
I dealt with all that.
Did you know in English when you came here?
Yeah,
we spoke English,
but it's pidgin English.
So we knew that,
you know,
were colonized by the European.
So the English has the word route or the words root words aren't from the
European.
So we knew English,
but it's just our take on it.
Uh,
and so how much different is pretty different?
It's very different.
Like if I was talking with another Nigerian,
I was speaking patient English,
you would pick out words,
but it's a little different.
What did he say?
Something in pigeon English.
Yeah.
I said nothing my right now we just sit down here just to talk now.
You,
you're not supposed to not judge did talk.
Just a Ui,
not be any tea.
That sounds cool.
It does it if like me and Israel out of zonules was talk and like it would be
mad cool Miller lite.
We speak it to each other.
So going from that to,
you know,
be in essentially raise and,
and,
and going through school.
And,
and one thing that,
um,
man,
I haven't,
I really haven't ever shared with anybody,
you know,
very,
very few people know,
is that my father has been incarcerated since 2009.
And,
and this is the first time really ever talked about it,
like been in caught.
My Dad was,
um,
it goes through a test is just the justice system here,
man.
It's so,
so,
so crooked and it's so backwards.
He has,
of course we're fortunate and like I,
there's so many things that we're thankful for live in here in this country
that,
you know,
you can sleep at night in your house and not worry about somebody breaking in,
robbing and killing you,
you know,
for the most par and to her.
And we're thankful for that.
We're thankful for the opportunities.
But my dad was a businessman and my dad built one of the,
uh,
a very,
very big business in Dallas.
He owned like an ambulance company.
And
you know,
it comes to a certain point where people just don't want youth to be your,
you're an immigrant and you were succeeding in a certain business there where
it's kind of like people don't care about it.
People don't want you to be there.
And you know,
it was one of those situations where my dad hired the people that he thought
were the right people to do what he didn't know the job to run his company,
why he could tend to a certain date.
He's like us,
like his family day to day,
different things that they cared about all to where they run the company into
the ground.
And now,
because my dad was the owner of the company,
they put it all on him,
even though the people that were doing,
you know,
the things that were really wrong and the company admitted to doing the wrong
things.
But what the court is saying is that,
oh,
because you own the company.
So ignorance is,
it's not an excuse.
So because of that we're going to sentence you to 15 years.
So he got sentenced when he did no crime.
Yeah,
it see the thing is the business again,
it,
my dad owned an ambulance company.
An ambulance company.
Yes.
So it was a transportation for emergency and non emergency,
you know,
and one thing that they,
he hired these like a Duh,
the paramedics,
the EMS to run the company because these people that they know the business.
So he had people that he hired from that acquire you acquire from a different
company.
But you know,
one thing that I would say is my dad's ignorance is,
is he didn't really do his research well enough on the guys that he hired.
So you hire a certain guys and now these guys were running the business and
these guys are like,
yeah,
we're going to make it,
we're going to help you grow this business.
Like any business,
man,
fuck yeah,
I hired the right people.
Yeah.
Helped me grow the business.
So now they're helping,
he's there doing that.
If he thinks,
okay,
I trust these guys,
they're taking care of the business and the,
the,
the most disappointing heartbreak and thinking about the businesses.
My Dad,
they're not,
they're not the one who does the billing,
the billing for the business.
They contract a difference,
an outside company to do the billing.
So it's not them doing it.
So they're doing the runs,
they're sending the notes to them.
This is the runs we did to you guys,
bill the government or whoever else to pay us.
My Dad is the owner.
He has people that are doing all this.
He's not,
they're running the day to day.
So eventually they go under investigation.
Although we're investigating nick,
I think maybe like 15 patients or something like that.
I don't know the exact number I 15 patients we're investigating for these runs
or whatever that would build these billing on them.
And so they put it all in investigation and they're like,
okay.
After a while they come back and they said,
all right,
we'll give you your stuff back.
Like,
we didn't really see anything,
but we'll give you your stuff back after they shut it down for a little while.
So damn,
now I gotta go back to bed.
So my dad's like,
oh,
fuck it.
I'm getting out of business.
They already killed my business for me.
So now it became one of the biggest company.
But you shut down for so long you've lost,
you know what you've worked for.
So now he's getting rid of it and getting out of it.
Then they come back later,
a few years later for the same thing that you've already said,
you're good here.
If you have your stuff back,
they come back and say,
Nah,
we're,
we're going to prosecute you for this.
So now those guys,
I,
and I've,
I've seen it,
this is obviously
how the feds work now,
those guys that you call it,
the EMS and these guys that were clearly did rule was wrong.
You gave them a deal and say,
hey,
we call it you guys,
because those guys started their own company doing the same shit.
So they get caught.
Now they're like,
okay,
we want that guy.
So you guys basically gave him a deal to say,
okay that guy,
it was in on it and my dad's life,
and I guess they offered my dad a deal,
a plea deal,
which his lawyer didn't really tell them about cause he had a court appointed,
a lawyer,
a lawyer.
So he said,
no,
I didn't do shit wrong.
Why would I take that deal?
Which would have been I think maybe like five years it was a deal or something
like that.
My Dad's like,
no,
I didn't do shit wrong.
Why would I take five years?
So he goes to trial and brought,
we've seen murderers,
we've seen all these people that are defraud the government and like stuck more
head funny guys,
billions of dollars get bail.
They said no,
they wouldn't even grant him bail.
My Dad's a citizen like turn over his passport and everything.
They said,
no,
I'm not going to give you bill.
We're going to hold you when a freeze,
all your accounts,
you can't really fight the case.
So you're stuck there and now your family's left with nothing,
with nothing,
no money in the account,
nothing.
And so my dad is deal with that and they just threw the book at him.
They're like,
you know,
we'll give you 15 years.
And this was 2009 and he's already been in for 10.
He has been in for 10 and,
and one thing that really killed me was um,
one thing,
uh,
it was a part in a trial where,
um,
the lawyer would basically tell him the judge like this guy's an upstanding guy,
no care record,
you know,
he has kids and look at his kids and how well they're doing.
His older son is in college.
The second one is in college.
The youngest is about to being in college.
These kids are all scholarships,
student athletes,
great student athletes.
And the one thing that killed me was the prosecution was like,
the reason that is is because he was defrauding the government from this money.
That's why they're in college.
And I was like,
wait,
my dad is not paying for us to be in college.
We're all student athletes.
We earn these.
We,
we worked hard earn scholarships as far as to being in college.
The defense didn't say that.
They didn't fucking say like,
you have a court appointed attorney.
I think he did borrow.
My Dad's just got railroaded man.
And it was like,
and it was so heartbreaking to where you,
you're telling them,
man that has raised his family,
raised his kids to,
to work hard,
get to a place in life and you're telling him that the only reason he's there is
because he cheated.
And it was just one of those things that added the chip on my shoulder at all.
Man.
There've been so many moments that added to put on my shoulder
with everything that I like.
I've been through so much that I just internalize and I compete with all this
energy.
And so for that you,
you telling my dad that?
Yeah.
Like you're going to sit down and I just,
and,
and obviously of course I researched more and more into that because I was so
heartbroken after that.
Like,
like you're just going to,
for what?
For how much you're saying not even up to almost a million.
They would this day just piled a lot of money on.
They're like,
oh,
this,
this and that for a little over other sane little over a million total,
which is nowhere near that.
You gave him 15 years when these guys hedge fund guys that that you can found
guilty for manipulating these markets for billions.
You give them six months house arrest if that,
and you were saying you're going to give him 15 years.
And I started researching,
I'm like,
a lot of these judges have stakes in these prisons and to what they do is they
give a lot of time because they get paid per prisoner.
That's,
and you know that story about that guy in Pennsylvania who was uh,
who was a judge and he was doing that.
He was sending kids to jail.
He was extending their sentences and giving them sentences from nothing.
And it turned out he had been getting paid by the prison.
A lot of them down the river.
Yeah,
I heard a lot of them get collect kickbacks and different things from that.
And so to put people there,
as you become more and more famous,
you could shed more and more light on this.
Yeah,
man,
it's your dad do for parole,
man.
I don't,
I don't even know.
I think soon listen to this podcast alone.
You talking about this could very well bring someone forward that wants to help
you with the appeal.
Yeah,
man.
And my mom,
my dad actually wrote,
cause during the Obama administration there was that whole clemency deal when
they,
when they were doing,
and my dad actually wrote a letter,
I actually have that letter,
I don't know where it put it,
but he wrote a letter to him.
And it was when I read the letter,
man,
I,
I can't help a cry about it because my,
my dad,
um,
it's my dad cares about his family so much and when I go see my dad because my
dad is so proud of me and uh,
and I'm so proud of him.
I mean,
he raised us so well and um,
to go see him in there.
And I mean it's not like he's sitting in the maximum security,
but for someone and tell you that you can't go home to your family at night for
telling.
You've got an year,
you got to sleep when we told you to sleep,
we got to,
you got to eat when we tell you to eat for 10 years.
And when you know,
I didn't do anything wrong because I chose to say no,
I didn't do anything wrong.
I'm not going to take the sentence you give me.
They say okay fine then you are going to sit in there for 15 years and there's
nothing you can do about it.
Is it man,
it broke my heart man.
And then when I think about it something I just hold it in cause I,
you know,
I try not to cry about it,
which I'm just like screw it.
I've have different situations that happen in life.
I'm like,
you know,
but I,
I ate that one up on the shoulder.
I put that chip homes.
You know what they're going to say that the reason
I'm here that was scholarship is because my dad,
they're saying my dad got money.
A little bit of money.
Are you serious?
What about the freaking hard work that I did to get here?
What about all the Times that I sat in a freaking hotbox might bathroom
upstairs,
which just trash bag on because I knew that I needed to get a pound off the next
day in order to be able to wrestle at this JV tournament.
What about all that,
you know,
that didn't make any difference.
You know,
the reason,
the only reason it was there is because of that.
What about all the times my brother ran,
worked hard to make national team when he was playing soccer or my little
brother getting numerous scholarship for a division one football everywhere like
that.
What?
So all that put a chip on my shoulder,
Joe,
to where it was like,
man,
I've got to succeed at all costs.
I don't want to really care.
And where,
where did this happen?
Where was this trial?
Uh,
in Texas and Dallas,
Texas.
Not the best place to have that job,
but uh,
uh,
it happened in a,
in a man,
a
put a sour taste in my mouth,
but um,
file an appeal.
Oh Man.
He filed an appeal at one time.
They didn't even look at it,
man.
It was like one of those things where it's like that judge,
they put you there,
you're there.
That was his domain.
They didn't even look at it like,
who cares?
Because I just feel like in the system you are in the UFC welterweight champion.
But I think that they treated him like that because you're an immigrant.
The system get in there and that's,
you know,
a Joe to wrap that,
put that on.
That's part of what this next fight symbolizes to me is the attitude that a lot
of people have towards immigrants as people are forgetting that Americans or
immigrants in that conversation in the last podcast,
he pulled up forgetting that our countries to where people have this attitude to
where something we're Americans go back to your country.
You know,
you,
you know,
go back.
This is a free country.
You this and that.
People like,
I always heard that growing up,
I always heard that and I always I,
the more I research,
I'm like,
what?
What are you talking about?
First of all,
this,
this whole attitude when you walk into a nail shop,
get your hand,
feet,
nails done.
Oh,
the majority of the people that run those nail shops,
Asians,
I'm not saying all of them in the world,
in the country,
but the majority of them in Asians,
but there's a lot of people that look down on all of it.
Like,
I'm not washing your feet.
I'm not going to do your nails known as people.
I take pride in that because that provides for them.
You know,
they do that,
you know,
but people,
people condemn it.
That's not a job people want to do.
When you go to these hotels and certain things,
who are the main people that are the maids that clean up the hotels?
A lot of them immigrants.
We take pride in them because now we're the country in a better place where we
can provide for families.
Those are jobs are a lot of people so called Americans.
The whole Colby,
Covington,
whole persona are like,
I'm above that.
That's the persona.
But then at the same time,
people now want to cry all the here taking our jobs.
Let's build a wall.
Let's keep them out.
They'd taken our job.
No,
they're providing.
They are helping this country get to its height.
The fact that you could come here and have someone do your nails,
so we'll clean your house and wash a car.
Someone do all this for you is part of what makes America so great.
One of the greatest nations in the world and the fact that they want to build a
wall.
You want to keep these people out.
You can't come here.
You can't bring your culture,
your stuff here is just,
it's saddens me and it upsets me as part of what this fight,
when it happens is Phi represents for me because I feel like that's the attitude
that this young man has.
He's entitled to,
I'm,
I should be USC champ.
You're your soy boy.
You know you can't,
you don't want dessert.
You can't hand with me,
boy,
that's his attitude.
He can't do this boy,
first of all,
who's your born?
I'm a grown ass man.
Don't fucking talk to me like that.
And that's the attitude that he has.
I'm entitled to this.
I mean I should be the champion because I am this way.
I'm American,
I'm this and ah Bro,
we're all American here.
And so that this fight is greater than than just me beating up a guy that's
talking a lot of shit.
There's a,
there's this fight means a lot to me.
So when I get the chance to put my hands on that guy,
let's just know this,
the wrath of every immigrant that have stepped foot in this country that I'm
going to put on him was you and your family are the ideal immigrants.
Absolutely.
Over overachievers.
I mean this is what like first of all,
what is it about Nigerians that do so well in this country?
That's one of the things,
if you look at like Nigerian immigrants,
like successful ratios of,
of different immigration groups,
Nigerians in particular are extraordinarily successful upon immigrating to
America.
Yeah.
I think it's a family,
a family thing.
It's like when,
when her family's decided and we get the opportunity to move to a better place.
The thing is that the whole persona is we're going to be able to sustain this
forever so my kids are not going to just play around and sports cause that's not
guarantee.
What is guaranteed is the fact that you're going to go to school when you're
going to become a doctor because you're going to get a job anywhere in the world
that you want.
That's why majority of them are doctors,
right?
Majority of doctors,
engineers,
because these are jobs that high demand jobs.
You always going to get a job anywhere and so that's all.
That's all we push.
You're going to be a doctor or you're going to be a a nine.
I'm an engineer.
None of them were saying,
you're going to be a professional athlete.
My parents,
hell no.
They didn't care for that.
Like I lied to them the first couple of years that I was wrestling.
I didn't tell him that.
You know,
my brother is a doctor and pharmacy in Dallas.
My little brother,
you know,
could have gotten the NFL.
It was a stellar football player.
Played at University of Houston and University of Arizona.
You know,
my sister now is in college.
She's in nursing school in college.
Like that's just what we push.
We want you to get a job that you can provide for your family forever.
Yeah.
They remind
me of Koreans and a lot of ways.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Super hardworking and appreciate once they've gotten to a place like America
where there really is no ceiling on the possibility.
You could do anything you want once you get here,
if you work hard.
Absolutely.
And then this is,
that's another thing that's dear to my heart is one of your Nigeria like when
you're in a situation that we were sad.
My mom was a teacher.
My mom owned a store to to a little convenience store.
When we did the little jobs on the site,
we told certain things on the side and on top of a raising three boys,
rowdy boys like that.
That's what we and the school we would it,
it wasn't like all it is the car,
the bus is going to pick you up at three 7:00 AM to go to school.
Nah,
the school is two miles away.
Three miles away.
You walk in,
you ready to get going.
Don't be late.
Cause if you got it,
if he was late,
he was gonna get a whooping before school started.
That's how it was.
And especially the education system is so high because you miss,
you miss a couple of answers on a test.
You had to go out and get a sweat and you are going to get whipped in school for
the answers that you missed.
10 was beat you in school.
Yeah,
absolutely.
The teacher,
the teacher,
the teacher was on,
first of all,
it's not teacher,
his uncle and aunt,
that's your uncle and your aunt in school.
They knew your parents did or your family,
they were going to whip you in school if you decided to mess up.
And that's how it was.
So that's why there's a lot of these smart Nigerians.
They get out and if there's no freaking job,
look,
we got to somehow make money.
It's so fucked up cause I don't want people to be kids,
but God damn when you put kids into that kind of pressure,
my parents put me in Catholic school for one year and I got excellent grades and
afterwards I was fucking terrible,
terrible man.
And I remember my stepfather said something May said,
your grades are only good when you were in Catholic school.
I was like,
Scott was fucking terrified.
I'm like,
it ain't a good move.
I mean,
it's not.
They're threatening me all the time.
They wanted to beat me and make me sit on a nail in the closet.
But it's this,
I don't,
I would never want you to go through that.
But the fact that you went through that is probably one of the reasons why
you're the man you are today.
That's humanity.
That's what I call humanity.
Because as human beings,
when we were growing like,
and you hear this all the time with parents want a better life for my kid.
I want a better life for my kids.
Yes,
absolutely.
That's what we want.
We want to present them with endless possibilities,
but you can't forget the fact that the reason you are the champion or the this
upstanding person that you are today's because you went to this hard things.
All these hardships molded you and,
and,
and that's part of the situation now is like,
everyone's like,
oh no,
I don't want these kids who play these sports is too tough.
They're too rough.
You know,
they could get hurt,
they can get that or that could could turn into a freaking champion.
He can get knocked on his butt times and that one's 51 at the time.
He gets up and says,
you know what?
Screw this.
I'm going to be a champion today.
All sold it.
You could do other things.
You could assign,
I think a guy like you could do anything.
But once you've achieved what you've achieved in,
in MMA and wrestling,
the kind of mindset that makes you push your body to the limit like that and
allows you to get your,
your you just,
just your body into the kind of condition that made you fight five rounds like
that against Tyron.
That's an extraordinary mind.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm thankful.
I'm thankful for a,
and this one thing that I always say is I'm thankful for every individual that
I've crossed paths with because when I really look back on my life and I
internalize a lot at things,
like how did I was a little,
I mean I was a freaking pipsqueak in Nigeria carrying this hot plate on my head
to go sell,
you know,
up and down the street.
God did I,
I never imagined that I would get to the point where I would run into all these
different wrestling coaches.
I would pour knowledge into me even if for every,
and this is just shout out to every coach.
If you ever saw me,
I was drilling a move and you came over and just corrected me or are you said no
on do it this way.
You know,
even if it's just a moment,
an inch in my life,
uh,
you did.
All of that contributed to the person that I am today,
to all those coaches,
all those people,
all my mentors that given me advice each and every one because I never knew that
I would cross paths.
Like,
look how crazy my life is.
I cross paths with John.
First time I ever seen him.
If I was John Joan,
I won my belt on the same card as Jon Jones.
You know,
I stayed,
when I went to visit John Jones,
I stayed in the same room that Colby Covington stayed in the following year when
he went to school with John Jones.
How fucking crazy is that?
That's pretty fucking crazy.
John's roommate was Joe Soda,
who also is in the UFC,
like,
you know,
it went to the University of Nebraska Carnie.
It became a national champion.
Same is true.
Trevell wrestle with Trevell delong,
them,
Joe and Jake Ellenberger.
Jake Ellenberger and EOC,
Joel Ellenberger in the UFC.
Like I look at the past that I've crossed in this alive to get me to this point
here.
I'm extremely thankful,
man.
I,
at the end of the day,
there's nothing that I can do that I can't,
I gotta give it up.
Like this was a plan.
I didn't,
this wasn't me.
And in control this say,
you know what,
when I'm 25 and when I'm this age,
I'm going to do that and do that,
do that.
And it all come together like that.
Like I've been blessed,
I've been very,
very blessed to cross paths with all these guys and,
and has gotten me to this moment.
So I'm,
I'm so thankful.
Well,
I think it's both.
You definitely have been blessed as,
as all of us have.
But besides just being fortunate,
it's you,
you went through the work,
you went through the work and you completed the process,
you know,
and that just the fact that you've fought Tyron motherfucking Woodley with a
broken foot in a hernia and still dominated him for five rounds is crazy.
You don't,
you don't get to that without having you built your mind and your body and in a
very crazy way and in a way through the the,
the fires of hard work and discipline.
You forged a champion.
Yeah.
I mean,
thank you Joe.
Like that.
That's it's all,
it all goes back to everything.
Like this is how my mind works is ever since I was little,
I'm one of those guys,
I sound silly,
but I'm a one trip kind of guy.
When I go to the grocery store and I'm bringing all that shit in the house,
I'm a lunch of kind of carried it in one trip.
I'm going to do it all of them.
I don't matter.
I don't care how much it is.
I'm going to try to do it a one chip and this is one thing that I say to myself
when I'm carrying all that stuff inside.
Yeah.
It hurts.
It's heavy.
Yeah.
This,
this makes no sense.
The cows is literally 50 feet from the,
from the car.
But my mind while I'm carrying all that heavy shit,
I'm just breaking.
Yeah.
Would one trip.
One trip can tough it get tough but tough.
I've been doing that since I was a kid.
Get tough.
You can do it.
You didn't do get tough or when I'm doing sets of of stuff reps in,
in the,
you know the coaches,
I had four sets of 10 I'm doing town.
When I get to like 10 I'm like,
oh I can do one more 11 let's get 11 boom,
get an extra set in.
I've been putting in extra set forever forever to where I feel like all that has
built me up to where my mind is today.
Where your mind is there,
but do you,
do you have a concern like what we were talking about before with Cain Velasquez
that your mind might be too strong for the tissue to strong for the ligaments,
too strong for the joints.
I mean this is what I worry about with a guy like you.
Yeah,
there's got to be mentally strong.
I have no fear of that at all.
No.
My concern was with a guy like Cain Velasquez got like,
there's,
there's certain people that I worry that they might do too much or pushed too
hard.
But the fucking problem is the only way you become a Cain Velasquez or become
you is to have that mindset to begin with,
Joe.
And how,
how else can you see Cain Velasquez fighting?
Can't say it,
can't stand,
can't see him training in any other way.
That's what made cane.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and I think that's all part of the plan.
Like there's a time for everybody.
There's a time,
there was a time designed for Tyron Woodley to become champion,
to be champion.
There's a time for me to be champion and to reign as a champion.
There's a time for everybody.
Of course,
I'm,
and like I said,
I like to take all these different knowledge that I get and I like to put it all
together.
So of course my coaches aren't now that no one had told me,
y'all are just go home like you,
you look great.
You teach my mind,
want to freaking go harder than,
I don't know what you do.
You've done great.
Go home.
So where I'm listening and I'm giving them the lead on that,
but the way I train is what's gotten me here and the way cane train is what's
gotten them there.
Now it's the responsibility of not just cane but everybody else that's around
him that he really confides to,
to let him know when it's too much and when it's not too much.
With Kane,
there's so many issues now because of the surgeries have been so extensive and
back surgery,
knee surgeries and reconstructions,
not just meniscus like you,
but the actual structure of the knee itself.
One thing that,
yeah,
one thing that I would always say is Cain,
you,
you can't always with with Kane,
with anybody else's,
the human body and the human mind is so powerful.
You can never say,
Oh man,
that's it.
It's over for that guy.
Or that guy is never going to be the same.
I just never know.
You never know.
Like cane,
you know much respect to,
can't,
can't come back and be a savage and still run through guys for sure.
Next year or two for sure.
Never know that the fix,
I don't know what the extent of that injury was,
but yeah,
I'm,
you know,
I'm hopeful and optimistic that he's going to be back soon,
you know?
But there's,
I feel like there's a time for everybody and if cane doesn't fight like that,
can you imagine cane fight in any other way of fighting?
Cautious point fighting.
Oh,
let me,
you can't.
No,
No one.
That's why there's an argument that is the best UFC heavyweight ever.
He's for,
so for sure one of the best UFC heavyweight summer.
Absolutely.
You know,
I mean not even a question.
Yeah.
Now when did they have you fighting Colby?
When is that supposed to take place?
I don't know.
You don't know?
I think it's a,
I have to get healthy furs for a long,
long time.
I'm in fighting her,
but I just like,
I don't want to send you down to Panama
and give you that guy's number.
We'll get off.
I'm going to contact Dr Reardon.
Give it to you.
I,
I've been fighting her for so long ago,
like whether it's knee or there,
there has been training camp so I could barely walk.
Like what not training,
walk,
walk for I think the last two years my daughter laughs at me.
I come down the stairs backwards.
Really?
I go down the stairs backwards because they at pressure on my knees,
Jesus Christ.
And my daughter laughs at me.
But I,
it was,
it was a time where I couldn't walk.
That's crazy.
Before the Leon Edwards fight,
I fought Leon Edwards years ago before that fight I could walk.
I mean I shit you not Joe walk down to and from the house,
from the car to the house.
It was,
it was in pain.
I walked on grass.
I couldn't walk on concrete because I felt like that relieved a little bit more
stressed.
It's like that's the extent of the pain that I've been in in some of these
fights.
That is fucking insane.
No,
this is during the camp,
during the camp,
just to make it to the flash.
Just walking on grass instead of concrete walking on grass instead of concrete.
Cause he's just,
it's Christ
and it does,
it is not as much hard,
hard surface to walk on.
So just when the fight came on,
do you just put it all sides?
When I walk to that cage,
fuck it.
Let's go.
This is a matter of me getting maybe $10,000 to $20,000.
I chose to be here and instead of sitting in the front of it,
instead of sitting at a desk,
Ma earning money,
so providing for my family,
this is how I'm going to do it.
And like I said,
Jo,
like my daughter,
little freaking fire on me,
Joe.
Yeah man.
When I,
those are adorable man.
And you had her,
he carried her with the belt.
I want her to uh,
me.
She,
yeah,
when she grows up,
I want her to remember that forever because um,
she lit a fire eye part of them.
Remember we were talking about,
um,
that the tank that you have in there,
part of why I'm a little scared to be locked in those tank is because I'm,
I've never been claustrophobic ever in my life.
I never was.
But there was a time when I found out that I was going to have her,
that my girl was pregnant with her at the time.
I,
um,
I'm freaking live with Rashad Evans.
I have no money in my bank account.
I'm broke as hell.
And
yeah,
I am having a child.
Yeah.
And I'm not married yet and these are,
especially,
these are these principles or your African parents,
I,
you've got to be married and things like that.
I'm not married yet.
Of course her mom is phenomenal woman.
Phenomenal.
And I'm not married and all this things and is happening.
I was fucking my mind.
I was panicking and I fight before that I just lost,
this was right after I lost the second fight.
Now I'm getting ready for the third fight.
And there was his doctor doctor's office that we go in and sleep in the
hyperbaric chamber because we heard it better for your body and stuff like that.
So I'd be doing it here and then once a week I go in and sleep in the,
like the plastic ones is zip you up in there and it compresses up.
And I was in there at one time,
I was in there and I started thinking,
I usually pass out and when I,
it starts to decompress,
I wake up,
I'm in that day and I wake up,
you know,
but it hasn't decompress yet,
so I never really thought anything of it.
Don't risk got it in there and I'm in this office in this room,
it's dark because they're the nurses.
They flipped a light off and they go on about their business,
tending to other patients.
And I'm like,
Okay Shit.
I gotta fight this fight.
I got,
I got choked out my last fight.
Wow.
Okay.
This shit might happen again.
There's,
do they say this dude is tough these days?
They saying this dude's tough.
He could scribe
to have a daughter.
Shit,
I'm proud.
Can I got no money?
I got to win this fight because I'm fighting for like $2,000 one at one.
If I went in $2,000 all this shit is going through my head.
Now this tech has in decompress.
The room is dark.
No,
I'm hearing nothing.
No nurses.
So now I start to get hot.
I mean the thing,
and I started getting a little hot in the Tang.
I'm like,
okay,
so now my body is getting a little hot.
I'm laying there now I start dripping it on my forehead is dripping sweat.
So I'm trying to control my relax bro.
You done this.
How many times relax,
you got this,
you got this takes,
you're good.
I can't see the clock.
So I don't know how much time's gone by now.
I'm freaking the fuck
my mind.
It's like I'm stuck in this too.
I didn't know what's going on.
I am I dying here.
I don't know what's going on these cause you gotta get me out of here.
No.
So I'm like relax with that.
So I'm bringing my mind back.
I'm relaxed.
Take a deep breath.
You're good.
You Go.
What she taught you?
Worried about.
Now I'm having this conversation in my mind back and forth and my relax,
you're good.
So I relaxed.
I'm like,
Oh,
I think how you got knocked as do that.
Jab,
want to bomb.
Okay,
so now I'm calm.
I'm calm.
But what if he coulda woulda left hand?
Boom.
Now you're knocked out.
Now I'm fucking sweating.
She says,
Joe,
I said,
know I was sweating so bad.
So I started tapping on the thing like,
you know,
I don't want to freak out because I still gotta be cool.
I want to let these nurses know,
like I'm freaking out.
I'm a fighter,
I'm freaking out in his tank.
So I'm tapping on the thing.
I'm like,
you know,
try to ask them like,
Hey,
uh,
how much time we got left just to at least hear another voice.
Nothing.
Nothing that they can't hear me cause it's loud.
The Tengiz loud and I'm
relaxed.
I'm full on panic attack in their full on panic attack and I'm trying to bring
myself back.
I'm calming myself down and I'm sweating heavily like profusely.
Now I'm dripping and all of a sudden I'm tapping this thing hard.
And a nurse walks in.
As soon as she walks in and flips the light,
I hear the machines start to decompress.
Oh fuck you,
thank God.
And I'm like,
ah,
she opens a you okay?
Like,
yeah,
I'm good.
You know,
just get a little hot,
but I had a full blown panic attack in there.
I have not been in a hole and a hyperbaric chamber said I tried it one time.
I probably could've done it,
but I just knew I couldn't really tell my body.
So damage at the time,
like I'm so crazy on my body,
I,
it's hard for me to tell.
It's supposed to heightened recoveries.
Yeah,
it's supposed to heighten it,
but I after that day,
like I,
I,
certain things kind of make me feel a certain way.
Like I've had tons of Mris after that,
but they freak me out because you put me in the Mri machine,
especially when you got to do the head ones.
I got to go in headfirst.
I don't like those.
I have to give my,
I have to give myself a pep talk and calm myself down and go in there to do
those now.
Like I just did one the other last week before I got my,
had my surgery and the lady's Trump put me,
I'm like,
Yo,
I just got an MRI.
I got the disk from the last one that I did last week.
The doctor said I could just bring this,
this gain and I'm good.
She's like,
the doctor wants us to get a new one.
I'm like,
you sure about that?
Like
I already got the same this year.
I'm like,
no,
we got to do.
I'm like,
how long is it going to be 40 minutes?
Fuck 40 minute.
Cause I,
my shoulders are wide,
so I'm in there tight.
Right.
And the machine is right here and it's making a noise and I,
and it's like,
yeah,
I'm just,
it's a,
I have to give my mind a pep talk and I'm just so relax bro.
Shoot me,
man.
Are you good?
You could,
you got this,
you can do this.
And I'll look at it.
I'm like,
let's go.
Let's go,
let's do it.
Let's knock it out.
Boom.
Then we're doing it and God forbid I,
I freaking wake up or my mind starts wandering 20 minutes in that I'm just
fucking halfway panic attack through the rest.
But I'll get through it.
Yeah.
It's scary,
but you know it since that day,
you know?
Um,
and he was,
it was crazy.
Like I,
at that point when I was pregnant,
we were pregnant in my daughter.
I was just like,
fuck,
am I going to survive?
I can't keep asking.
This grown man Rashad,
that works hard to support me.
I can't do that.
I got to make my own.
I kind of do this.
So I was scared.
I was good.
I know what's going to happen.
And then all of a sudden,
you know,
right when we were having her,
we have her boom,
boom.
The opportunity comes up.
We're going to do the ultimate fighter.
I said,
no,
I don't want to do the ultimate fighter.
And they were shot.
I was like,
Yo Bro,
you got to do this.
I fucking end up doing the ultimate fighter.
Boom.
I win the ultimate fighter.
I fight for the finale.
Boom.
I do this like roller coaster,
boom,
boom.
All the hard work,
everything that I'd been putting it,
boom.
Starts paying off,
paying off.
Now I'm making 10 and 10.
Okay.
You feel like that's,
that's enough to be able to,
you know,
sustain me until I got to fight again.
It got to fight again.
You gotta fight it.
Yeah.
Boom,
this happens,
this happens.
I get with,
you know,
amazing manager,
Aliyah Abdulaziz who freaking,
you know,
help just transform the career,
take it to the next level,
you know,
get with him and now things are going the way that I,
I've been wanting them to go boom,
boom,
everything's ma'am.
And it was just,
it's just motivation to keep working like,
and every time I look at my daughter,
how innocent she is,
how sweet and wonderful she is,
man.
He just freaking,
it transforms me to where I'm at.
There's a video and I even have a video of,
of,
uh,
of her,
cause she's been coming to the gym with me ever since she was six months old.
I used to take her to the gym.
Mom's at work,
she'd come to the gym with me.
And when she comes to the gym,
she knows what I do.
She watches me do it all the time.
This is video where she's,
she'll has,
she has a gloves and she hits the bag too.
When I,
when I work out and I was doing a search,
I was getting ready for a fight and she's running around with me and she's chair
yours.
She's like,
let's go daddy.
I'm so proud of him at like tailored to my coach and she's like,
come on Daddy.
Like,
ah.
And I watch those videos and I'm just like,
I was always one of those hard guideline,
man.
I ain't gonna be no sucker when I have kids.
Like that ain't going to be acting like that.
I can't watch a video with her and not smile is the craziest thing to me and
don't have children.
We'll never totally understand that.
I know it's a different,
it's a different fire that they light underneath,
man.
And I'm not going to get motivated.
Once you have kids,
you're never going to get motivated to know that.
You probably shouldn't have just been doing that anyways.
It changed my life for sure.
Yeah,
she is.
Um,
she's,
she's sees my little,
she's my little rider.
She rides with me.
She,
I love her to death,
man.
I can't,
nothing can,
I can't explain it.
She is.
She's my,
she's my plus one.
That's what I class my bus.
No matter whatever I do in life from now on,
she's a plus one.
She's with me.
That's amazing.
I got to find the video but it's so funny.
It's so funny when I'm,
I'm,
I'm doing like a circuit and I'm running around and you could see her running
around like,
come on Daddy.
I'm so proud of him.
So she's just hanging out and like no one's watching her.
No,
she just has this little girl like that was in two,
six months old.
I put it in a stroke in her car seat and just put her by the side of Matt.
Boom.
Should just watch me train for two hours.
Wow.
Two hours to when she got to a certain point where we had like a daycare in the
gym and she would go in the gym,
she would go to the daycare and she was,
she was good there.
And then to the point where now,
like the kids that are in our gym are around similar age and our coaches,
wife Henry Pooky,
she does a good job and she would just watch them,
you know?
But they govern themselves.
They're just play around and the other side and run around.
But it's not like they around harmful things in the jam,
you know?
They just have a good time.
That's great that you have that environment.
Yeah.
And she's like I said,
and like a lot of people are like,
Oh man,
she's so beautiful.
You know,
you,
you're going to meet.
Nah,
I'm not worried.
Like my daughter's going to have a nice one too,
and a hard low kick and whoever can deal with that.
Hey,
wow.
Yeah man.
But yeah,
she lit that fire and uh,
and I dreamt about that moment.
So it's still surreal,
Joel.
I think about that moment,
like when you were interviewing me,
like I freaking forgot your name.
I'm like,
Joe,
wait,
your name is Jay.
Yeah.
Your name is Joe.
Fuck.
That's gotta be surreal when they put that belt around you for the first time.
Yeah.
Because I imagine there's so many times,
no,
he'd be,
oh,
let me ask you some honestly,
do you like the new belt or the old bill?
Initially I used to talk sounds like man,
Nah,
cause that's the only picture,
that old picture.
And we're human beings.
People don't like change.
You know,
that was the thing.
I was like,
Oh man,
this shit look like a space.
But that fucking
thing is phenomenal.
That's your belt.
Phenomenal.
I they knew belt now is phenomenal.
It's amazing.
Beautiful.
It's beautiful.
Of course I always wanted that old bell,
you know.
But now it's like comparing it to it now.
Like this new belts got of this colors of this country flags on it and that
stones,
it's amazing.
I,
you know the people that are all the ones that are still hating on it and say,
oh no,
wait till you put that belt on and you wait till you hold that thing and it's
super heavy and it's amazing.
It's amazing.
I love it.
What did you think about that?
Uh,
the deal today,
we're,
all the paper views are going to be on ESPN plus a fucking UFC baby.
These guys,
hey is always a way to cut out the middle man.
I guess so.
Yeah.
Hopefully this is the thing is my hope is now the paper view scale for the
fighters bumps.
That's what I hope.
But I hope the numbers stay high because people have to subscribe now.
Oh was I believe?
I'm not sure.
That can't be because if you're paying your money like all,
unless you get it free,
like,
because if you're going to put this chain,
it says you have to subscribe to ESPN plus in order to get a paper view.
Well how does that work with people that are out of the country?
I believe it's cheaper than,
I think it's the same price you're paying at the end of the day.
Cause I think it was like 65 or 70.
But you know,
you get a subscription instead of 65 and he comes at the Sif Christian.
Right.
So you have,
but do you have to subscribe and you can cancel at anytime so you can subscribe.
So you have to re,
what if someone only wants to buy one or two paper views a year?
They resubscribe every time,
I guess.
Yeah,
I mean,
yeah,
I mean it's,
Eh,
it works.
I mean,
if you really want to,
I hope it doesn't mess with the numbers,
but the thing in sharp was in here,
so he could talk some shit and I can't talk some shit about this,
but if Shaw was here,
oh man.
Brandon,
another guy that's,
I think Brendan's doing his shows got big.
It's huge.
Like I was doing phenomenal.
I went to one of his shows down in Florida,
West Palm,
Florida,
and um,
I fucking spend a shot,
but I didn't think he was funny.
I guess I was bored and I was like,
let's go to a Brenden's job show.
And I go,
he was freaking funny.
Like he told,
he told the whole story man.
And I was impressed,
man,
man.
Hats off to Brendan Schaub like he was fun.
He basically,
all he did was tell his story of what's going on,
what went on in his life and his career.
But the shit,
the twist,
it was freaking funny.
I went backstage towards the end,
I was like,
man,
that shows funny.
I didn't think you were funny and without that was,
that was amazing.
I loved it.
Well he's showing fighters if is a path outside of fighting.
Absolutely.
He makes way more money now than they ever made during fighting times and he's
doing well and he's happy and he's,
he fulfilled,
he's got two great podcasts and he's doing,
he does comedy shows just to just film to show time special and he's doing them.
That's amazing.
And which is,
oh excuse me.
Part of like all this whole shit people given tarnish it and giving him shit
for,
you know,
doing music or doing movies and all this stuff like that man.
Naw Man.
More power to them.
I'm,
I'm glad that he's doing that because that's what we want.
You want all this different revenue streams where you don't have to get punched
in the face for 50 you got to have a dual strategy.
Yeah.
And I,
and I love that and I appreciate that.
That's what I want to do.
Like can you freaking imagined [inaudible] Francis in the next Black Panther?
Like you can see it,
right?
Like what?
Perfect.
We should definitely be in that.
Whoever's making that movie,
cast him for that.
Hey,
yeah,
Frances in Ghana,
you don't need the teachers' accidents at all.
Like I'm from,
I'm from Nigeria,
there's no team.
You have to teach me.
You have my accent.
You can teach them,
you know?
Yeah.
I can teach them.
So authentic.
Yeah.
So I commend them for that man.
You know,
one of the thing and exit strategy.
Absolutely.
I think I want to do all that.
Like I know I've been commentating,
I work with Titan.
They'll see down and south like tighten this amazing show to,
you know,
I come and take it out of there.
I mean they,
sometimes I'm watching Fox,
I'm like fuck these guys fought each other for a 101 crazy like good cause they
want to get into the big show.
Absolutely man.
Yeah.
I'll commentate for them.
That's how UFC fight pass,
right?
UFC fibers.
Yeah.
And so,
um,
yeah I want to get into movies.
I,
I've been,
you know,
practice and I,
I think I could do it.
Like I'm not in no way saying what they do is easy.
Like those actors,
I know they work hard to be able to transform and make people feel a certain way
and evoke certain emotions from different people with your characters.
That's a real art.
So I respect that and I want to learn more about that.
And Yeah,
I definitely want,
I want to do movies to get more famous.
Richard and I get punched in the face.
Oh for sure.
Absolutely.
What about doing a podcast?
You ever thought of that?
Yeah,
I would love it.
You know,
I just haven't been approached with the right,
you know,
with the right situation.
Beautiful thing about podcasts.
You don't need anybody.
Yeah.
You don't need shit,
you just need a fucking tape player.
You could use it on your phone,
you can record what you think.
There's great little tiny microphone that stick in the bottom of your iPhone and
it worked great and you just sit down and talk about shit.
Yeah,
we'll have to give that a try.
And when I don't want right now is,
it's strange that distract me from,
because I,
I'm not one of those guys who were,
oh yeah,
I've got to find out.
I got to be in training camp and you know,
and if I don't have a fight I'm just doing what the fuck I want to freaking
practice every day I'm going to practice cause I,
it's like my life right now.
Does he know?
I don't know what to do if I don't go to practice.
So you're recovering from the surgery?
Yeah,
I'm going to try some different things.
Does it feel good though to just like slow down a little bit,
smell the roses?
Not really because this whole week I couldn't freaking train.
Like,
I wanted to go to the gym and I at least hit the back.
Excuse me,
hit the bag or something.
Or just,
you know,
cause I think I'm an addict of that burn of course,
that,
that burn of an orc out and it's lifting or pushups or doing some pushing
yourself.
I'm an addict of that and so when I don't have that,
it's kind of like what's it doing you,
you,
and that's what made you the champion.
I mean that that engine that's inside you is what made you the champion.
It only makes sense.
Yeah.
If you,
if you really could just relax and kickback,
I'd be nervous.
Yeah.
Ugly like down shifting because that's what they say.
They're like,
oh you change,
you change.
Use different person now you know you don't got Hollywood on us.
You don't,
I fucking hate when people say that.
Yeah.
That's a gross thing.
People just love to come up with some excuses for why they don't do as well as
you are.
Why Oh,
when I was going to bring up too is that I saw you do a cause when I started
researching you and watching your stuff,
I saw the podcasts.
You deal with a freaking Jamie Foxx years ago or so.
He's amazing.
Fucking I,
I,
I mean I'm such a huge,
I'm a huge Jamie Foxx.
He's fucking talented.
I mean talking to about the triple threat,
he could do any,
how many people can do it does stand up comedy and like chicks are in trouble.
Sings incredible.
Yeah.
Women are in,
Oh my God can make you laugh.
He can say her name [inaudible] with his voice and he can freaking act and I
want to do is you're lucky he's not gay.
They me in trouble.
He's got an amazing man.
He's,
he's such a genuine guy too.
Cause I mean I've known him for a long time,
but he's a fucking academy award winning actor.
When he comes in and hangs out with you,
you would never imagine it.
I that's,
that's what I grabbed the energies like that is what I grabbed it to normal.
It's like Rashad Evans shot is the same way and those energies I really
gravitate towards and I love,
there are people who don't take themselves seriously,
but they do,
they do horse like they do,
but they don't pretend they're better than you or anything.
Like I ran into,
Jamie had a fucking gas station like a 66,
seven months ago.
Some guy.
What time was this normal time like during the day he was actually with his
daughter.
She was coming from a martial arts class and uh,
I'm getting gas and this guy pulls up in this crazy fucking car.
Like I never saw one of these things before.
I forget what it's called.
Some weird SUV.
It looks like it's from the future.
Like,
oh,
the Lamborghini.
Yes.
You know?
No,
it's not a Lamborghini.
It's some crazy.
He knows the guy who makes them crazy.
I mean,
I don't even know what the fuck it is.
I never saw him from like,
what is this thing?
And I'm looking at this thing and then the do rolls down the window.
It goes,
what's up Joe?
What's up Jamie?
I go into the fuck is this man,
he's so normal.
He jumps out of the car and starts talking.
People just start coming up to him and he's like,
Hey,
what's up?
How you doing?
Just totally normal.
I kind of,
I feel a little bit of that because it's tired cause I still do the same shit.
Like I,
I'm still,
I still go to the same little nutrition shop that I go to get a protein shake
here and there and I still go to this thing.
Like I took my daughter to the movies before I left to go to the iPad and I just
roll in.
It's just me,
me and her.
Perfect.
You know what is freaking role in it?
As long as you can.
People I and people ask for pictures and uh,
and I think one guy one time,
Zack Brock and fuck,
I can't believe you're here bro.
Like,
Bro,
you serious bro?
Like this one guy was like,
Bro,
you hear me?
Whose mom,
Bro,
can I get it bro?
Can I get a picture with you bro?
He almost like quiet.
And I was like,
I was like,
yeah bro.
Of course you can get it.
Yeah,
you want me to take it?
Which angle you want me to take a couple?
I'm just snapping a picture and I'm kidding.
But it just couldn't believe the fact that I'm normally,
people are just normal people.
We're just normal.
People are just people.
They're just wonderful.
And I think one of the great things about someone who accomplished or something
it's pretty spectacular is that you didn't just do that and win the world title,
but you set a lot of people in motion.
You know how many people watch that and must been pumped up and excited about it
and then started doing things.
It's probably a lot of people that decided to start fighting because watch,
I mean millions of people watch that fight.
So stop and think about how many different people must have been inspired by
that.
How many different people saw the highlights on Instagram and on Twitter and on
Youtube and how many people got fired up because of that.
And that's what I'm thankful for.
I'm thankful for the opportunity.
Shout out to the UFC for creating such a business and a market now,
and two words,
you can touch so many people all across the world because that's in fighting is
one thing that's a universal language.
It doesn't matter if you fucking speak Russian,
you speak English,
you speak,
you know,
equal or euro by doesn't matter.
You know,
fighting this,
this,
nobody knows this.
You don't have to know the rules.
Everybody.
It's not like cricket.
Yeah,
it's universal.
So it's one of those things that that's a sport that's going to,
it's going to grow is only gonna get bigger and bigger.
Man,
shout out to the UFC,
Dana,
you know,
hundred all these guys,
Lorenzo Fertitta,
all these guys that created this and package it to the where it is now because
it's given us platforms to be able to touch people and yeah.
And that I truly am.
I'm aware of what that could have done for certain people.
Certain people.
Yeah.
It might have not thought him in individual person,
but someone,
you know,
I might've inspired someone to start fighting that come from where I come from
or somewhere in China,
Indonesia,
anywhere in any world.
Yes.
I'm thankful.
I'm very thankful for that.
Yeah,
I mean that is a big part of what a champion is.
I mean,
we were talking earlier about Marvin Hagler or d different fighters that I
watched when I was a kid coming up.
Those people give you energy.
You know,
this is something about watching someone do something spectacular.
They give you energy and when you hear a story like yours,
you know,
a kid who immigrates to the United States at eight years old and goes through
all the shit that you went through and becomes a world champion.
People hear that man.
It makes it,
gets them off the fucking couch,
man.
It gets them to do things.
It does.
And,
and um,
uh,
thing about during that fight is there was two other guys at two special guests
that I had come to the fight and they were both Nigerian nightmares,
you know,
and they're respectful,
rise sports.
And write a Christian a coin,
you know,
Kansas city chiefs running back was called the Nigeria nightmare because he was
a fucking terror.
You know,
Chrissy,
you getting a whole Christina Coy,
I don't know anything about football able itself.
Jamie's laughing man is with us.
Yeah,
he was a fucking monster man.
He was like,
uh,
I think he was 200 like 260 pound running back.
Like I'm talking Mack truck run into do boom,
boom,
boom.
And you know,
and he has speed and power.
So he was considered in Nigeria nightmare.
So he was one of those first guys that people really resignated as a Nigeria
nightmare in American sports.
And I never watched him play live,
of course not.
But these are the guys that they create such a legacy to where when you're
growing up somehow you hear about that legacy.
And that inspired me to want to be great bearing that nickname.
And also Samuel Peter's aren't,
if,
you know Pete Samuel,
Peter have WBC heavyweight champion of the wall was at the fights and man,
these guys are,
man,
I didn't,
I never saw him fight live.
But he creates such a legacy to where I heard about him.
I had to research them and these guys inspired me to where now having that
nickname you gotta you know,
I have to hold it to the highest regards.
I have to do the best that I can to be able to inspire many,
many kids that are going to come,
you know,
in the future.
So man,
I,
I'm,
I'm thankful for the opportunity and I'm just grateful as I'm,
I'm a,
I'm a humble,
a little kid from Nigeria,
you know,
I used to walk around barefoot,
step on nails,
glasses,
you know,
things like that.
And now look where we at now he rock his shoe designers,
baby
welterweight champion of the world.
Undisputed.
Yeah,
man.
And it's pretty incredible.
Yeah.
Does it feel real?
I mean,
I,
I'm still feel normal.
I don't feel anything,
but you know,
you're the champ.
Yeah.
I mean,
but I think part of why it feels the way it does it,
because I've,
I've known for a long time,
like I,
I felt like it for a long time.
I've,
I've known nothing's going to change the way I'm going to train for these fights
and I'm just going to train change in my mentality.
I'm gonna approach these fights all the same.
It's still a fight is a fight.
It's not all I'm trying to defend this or I'm trying to hold onto this.
I don't give a shit.
I'm still going in there to dominate you from start to finish,
to break you mentally.
So you want to freaking fight me again.
That's my approach to every fight.
So nothing changes.
I don't feel different.
Everyone,
the only thing now is as cord Pete.
Everyone's like,
treat me a little different.
People kind of,
you know,
people hold doors for me now and shit like that.
Hopefully you're making a shitload more money.
Well,
yeah,
let's,
uh,
Dana,
hopefully,
uh,
hopefully that,
but um,
that's the only difference.
Like I don't feel different.
I don't act any different.
I,
at least at home,
no.
When we were talking earlier about guys who like to trash talk and what trash
talking is kind of doing for the sport,
whether it's good or bad,
you know it's,
some guys are really funny with it.
Like Connor's fucking hilarious with it and they say something about that.
That is like when Jeremy Stevens said something about,
he was like,
who the fuck is that guy?
I mean
the most famous line if I again Emma that it's,
yeah,
I mean it's,
I mean,
oh man.
I mean how many times has that been repeated?
A shout out to Jeremy Stevens.
I guys come and scrap always.
But I think that that's not the only way a guy can sell a lot of paper views.
Guy Can also sell a lot of paper views by being exceptional.
And that was the case of George St Pierre.
Like George St Pierre was never a trash talker and it's still sold a shit load
of paper views,
I think.
I think we're as human and human beings,
humans can kind of tell the energy.
It's a fake energy.
See people can tell people are put off by it.
Well people who are also a namerd of people that are exceptional,
you know,
if you just,
you can just be exceptional.
You don't have to just be talking shit all the time and pushing each other at
press conferences is not the only way.
No,
but then you get those,
you know,
you get the majority of the,
the the Shitty Fan who who likes that stuff wants to see a too.
Yeah.
There's a few.
So who,
even though they know it's fake,
they just still like that.
They just,
well they want to see it,
you know,
so they put that pressure on people like you know,
you got to do this,
you have to do that because those are the guys that are going to tweet.
You don't,
do they tell you?
No.
I'll give you advice on how to talk or no.
I mean data's never once said,
you gotta talk,
you gotta do this.
You got no,
they don't do that.
Do you feel though that sometimes they show you that by favoring guys who do do
that?
Like,
like when Colby got a shot at the interim title before you.
Yeah,
because this is the thing is when someone starts doing that and they're starting
to trend a lot more,
of course the company gets behind them because the company is about money.
It's about green.
Like they gotta make money.
That's the one thing that I understand more than anything right now.
They are about green.
Like people will say,
oh Danny hates me cause this Natalie,
they didn't the only race day and cares about is green.
Like if you're going to make money,
Dana cares.
And so nothing that once someone starts doing it and they're starting to create
a little,
they started to have a little buzz.
Of course Dana is going to push because dag eyes my bring in money making more
money.
So I understand that aspect of it,
but it's not,
I don't think is Dana necessarily saying all may you got to act like does you
got to do this because this is what sells.
Know Conor did it and if Connor Connor became who he became,
so yeah,
Connor is going to be favored because Connor brings in millions and millions of
dollars.
Habib did it his way and now hubby brings him when he,
you know,
he's favored,
so he's going to bring in money and things like that.
But Dan is not going around saying,
Yo,
you gotta be like this guy.
You gotta be like that guy.
You know?
Bisbing did it his way,
home base being brought in money.
George did it his way.
It's just as long as you want to be real,
you,
what you choose to do,
you're going to be real with yourself.
Because at the end of the day,
you have to look at yourself in the mirror.
Yes.
If you can do what you want to do and then at the end of the day,
look in the mirror when everyone's gone,
it's just you.
You take a piss in the morning and then you wake up linking yourself and your
man.
You're like,
oh,
I'm all right then that's fine.
Do they do you beautiful?
Beautifully put.
You're a bad motherfucker.
Tomorrow.
My man,
thanks for doing this,
man.
Thank you.
It's a pleasure.
Thanks for telling me your story and inspiring people and I wish you nothing but
the best.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Tomorrow it was spawn,
ladies and gentlemen,
the champ.
Hm.
Okay.